Okay,
this is all about the right-wing like panel sphere. These guys
do a bunch of debate panels, open call-in shows. There's a ton
of these on YouTube. They make pretty good money. Um, Andrew
Wilson
kind of collabed with this raging tomato woman and he would he
would bring a bunch of his audience over to watch her stuff and
they kind of formed like this symbiotic relationship where she
would book stuff for Andrew, Andrew would get debates and then
occasionally because she would book debates with Andrew and and
serve as somebody who Yeah. would would just book him or get
him debates with people as a neutral >> Uh he would go
on her show and he would like drive donations to her show.
>> Yes. Because you would she would host debates and you
get the debaters on and their audience will come over and start
enjoying it because after you do the scheduled debate, you'll
have an open panel and that's good content for people and that
gets audience participation. Then they get like a new watering
hole kind of thing. >> Yeah, exactly. There's an AI song
that goes along with this whole drama. Now what is this? >> It's
me Sarah the raging tomato back to moderate another debate show.
>> These people these people get so mad. Oh it's a speak
easy video.
These people get like so mad.
Um I don't >> mad about what? >> Oh just it's Sarah
the aging tomato. Get >> So speak easys listen and make
no mistake. Okay. Speak easy runs this second biggest right-wing
like panel show. It's almost exactly a one to one copy of >> Does
he >> raging Tomatoes? Yes, they're the not a copy necessarily.
I don't know which one came up first, but they do the exact same
thing. And so if you can't see what this is, transition is him
angling for the Andrew Wilson spot.
>> Someone watching must have a clip of the the the tribute
to the dead kid. Someone watching has to have this.
>> The only way I know the dead kid. I could not come up
with Speak Easyy's name last night or the night before and I'm
like where's Queman? It's the guy who has the dead kid tribute.
I couldn't figure I couldn't remember his name and Queman I that's
the only thing I had in my head was Queman has to bring up this
tribute to the dead kid with regards to speak easy every time
he's mentioned. >> Who's a dead kid? Is it little? >> I
don't think it's his kid. No, it's like some random kid that
he's talking about. He does like a musical tribute to
But yeah, in any case, guys, this uh Speak Easy going after Raging
Tomato, obviously just trying to get in with Andrew Wilson um
to be like the the guy who Andrew Wilson goes on his debate panels.
And trust me, I this is not really this is not really confusing
cuz I I do believe you can get, you know, probably a double or
tripling of your income if you get this spot where Andrew Wilson's
going to go to your stuff. He'll work with you and and he'll
hop on your panels to, you know, throw elbows with people. That
is a massively beneficial spot to have. >> I don't think
it's going to be Speak Easy because Speak Easy is almost certainly
a little too DGEN for Andrew Wilson to professionally associate
with, but we'll see. What were you going to >> I just I'm
going to be the
I'm going to be consistent. It was gay when people did this to
Kelly. It's gay when they do this to any woman. Like the whole
aging thing. >> Oh, yeah. >> Women attractive. You
cannot go after their looks. So, you try to find something else
to poke at. Who cares where her age is? She looks really good.
>> And I'll say uh actually actual party foul here from
uh from Speak Easy or at least a miscalculation. Are you really
going to go and say Sarah's like aging or or you going to use
this against Sarah in a way where Andrew Wilson didn't? He typically
doesn't and he's got a wife who's what 30 40 years old as well,
right? She's got to be like 40 years old. >> Like I'm sorry,
men are aging too.
>> More gracefully. >> But yeah, this is a conservative
person. Anyway, I just I my
>> that that's my role. >> I just I don't know, man.
I think um
I think this is a miscalculation. I don't think how this is how
Andrew Andrew wants Sarah to go down for being a betrayer, not
for being like old or a woman or anything like that. He wants
her to go down for stabbing Rob in the back, which is a little
dubious, but we'll we'll take a look. We'll see see what the
thoughts are. All right. So,
I'll give I'll give the song a minute 30. If it picks up, if
it hits at all, I'll finish it. Otherwise, I'm gonna go back
to the Andrew's video. >> But it's my rules, not yours.
>> I'm fair.
I'm already in there. Interrupting
midpoint, taking the mic, pretending to host, but I'm ready to
strike. They think I'm sweet. We're red for the cause. Talking
like I'm But it's feminist laws. Conservative cosplay, money
in hand, I bathe the bears just like I planned.
Oh, Andrew built my little empire.
Now I'm acting like I'm
>> So you guys might not know this if you don't follow
any of this uh this whole like scene here. You might not Yeah,
it's not great. You might not understand, but this is all of
Sarah the Raging tomatoes branding. She does this like circus
branding for her big like chaos panels where a whole bunch of,
you know, four viewer streamers come on. Not on them, just like
smaller streamers come on and and just talk to each other and
talk about whatever topic. All right. So, she's she's kind of
famous for this is all her branding. It's like kind of maybe
took some effort. I don't want to sh it too badly, but not for
us. All right. We don't even get the inside references. We're
just here for the drama. Andrew Wilson, his video does a good
job of setting it up. And if we need to, we can go and fact check
some stuff. I got all the source material as well. If we need
to go and review, you know, Andrew says this happened and we
feel like it's out of context, we can go take a wider shot look
at it. So, let's give this a go. >> No matter what you
do, no matter what >> I'm going to have to back it up here.
Give me a second. >> People Sometimes people just don't
learn. They just don't They just don't get it. No matter what
you do, no matter what you say, they just don't get it. lot of
people who have carved a pretty good living off of The Crucible.
For instance, if you go to Sarah the Tomato's channel, her top
18,
just just put most popular in her live.
The top 18
meaning the >> Is he really? Oh my god,
>> he's on all of them. Uh >> Best 18 videos that
she has. The top
Sherry, did you see that Ben Stellar
>> I just You mentioned this to me. I wasn't around in
the scene at all back >> Ben Stellar. >> Ben Stellar
in the chat. >> Oh, no. What' he say? Right. That's what
I thought. Ben, this does feel I feel like I'm reliving the the
drama between uh Andrew Wilson when he was big papa fascist and
Britney politically provoked where it was her setting up panels
for him specifically, but Andrew didn't have his like own individual
platform at this time. So
>> like close. >> Oh. Oh, sorry. >> Andrew
didn't So they were like they were
kind of working together,
I think. And I don't want to get the story wrong. So I kind of
wanted JTO to reach out to Andrew to see if he could if if Andrew
even felt like it was similar. But uh at certain point the people
who would join the panels after the big debates, one of them
was um Mayo or Mayo and >> Mo just
>> that's fine.
and Mio just sort of started getting like favoritism from Britney
or she just she really wanted people to start talking to him.
She kind of saw him as being like a really good debater and then
it almost felt like preferential treatment to like the other
people and I think to Andrew Wilson.
>> I forget what devolved from there. we could see. So,
I'd heard and I I >> there's definitely a video on it that
I >> There's almost certainly like uh I think Mio was kind
of groper adjacent and that but yeah, we you know, we should
look into it instead of just going on. >> Yeah, I don't
want to do speculation. >> Yeah, we can we can look into
it after. >> It does sound familiar. I agree with you,
Ben. >> Big split between politically provoked and Andrew
Wilson. Although Andrew Wilson clearly way more money involved
this time, right? Like he's got a massive donation pool. She's
catching a lot of those donations. A lot of her big videos on
her channel are from Angie Wilson joining, >> which is
why I think he's gonna talk here like he knows something because
he's been through this, right? He's not >> Dude, did she
really use that aerodite picture? Is that really is feminism
good for society? He used that Aerodite >> What a picture?
>> That's crazy. Can you see this on this on the top left
of that thumbnail?
>> I'm just like, dude, everybody else got a normal picture.
They just take the worst aerodynite picture from her stream to
use as her thumbnail. I'm just saying you want somebody to come
back for your panels. That's kind of crazy.
>> But somebody said Britney who? This is Britney. Her
name is like politically provoked and I think she she's just
like on cozy now.
>> Yeah. I don't even know if she does a show anymore.
I actually I have >> Oh, I have no idea. Don't check over
>> Are all me.
>> I didn't even know I had appeared 18 times on Sarah
the Tomatoes channel.
I didn't even know I had been there 18 times, but the 18 times
I was there are the best performing videos
on the entire channel. Isn't that interesting? Isn't that interesting?
little bit of drama pop off. >> J, you can't talk. I don't
even know. I don't even know what this one Well, he's saying
something about thumbnails here. One, you're talking about Riyle's
thumbnails. Two, the people Riyle throws like the really gross
thumbnails at are people who aren't going to come on the channel
anymore. So, I get all the room to talk if that's what you're
talking >> I woke up this morning. >> I thought he
was trying to say because you um you used to have people on your
stream all the time, but you are not you're not like a panel
host or anything. You you're like a streamer on your own.
You'll have guests on sometimes. Why are you giggling? >> Sorry.
Uh cuz you're you're uh nothing. It's fine.
>> I'm just laughing cuz it's like I don't need to Nothing.
I don't need to defend
>> Well, I thought that that was the >> Oh, maybe.
>> Why would anybody attack you for You don't make thumbnails.
Everybody knows you can't even do Photoshop. >> Does Wait,
what are you talking about? I can't do Photoshop. >> You
didn't know how to put a watermark on your own clip on >> That's
different. That's video editing. That's way different. >> I
don't think that that's different. >> That's way different.
>> By this morning, I mean late afternoon.
and uh was listening to Rob No
ranting
and a raven
on his channel and I was like, "Well, what's what's all this
about? What's Rob upset about?"
>> Oh, okay. Hold on. I'm like I'm two seconds away from
just doing it. Okay. >> Oh, it was about fat arite. Never
mind.
>> Riyle did that >> from just doing this. Guys,
uh welcome welcome to the channel. Uh how y'all feeling tonight?
Should we do the radio voice like Andrew is right now? Should
we drop into some radio voice with the with the lows all all
booming?
>> No. No, he's not trying to do that. That guy smokes
so much he can't help the register that his voice will still
activate in. >> Okay. All right. I I did an equalization
thing there, too. >> Oh, okay. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Tuning
in and laughing
as he kind of was covering what was going on. But let me explain
>> So this would have been back when the video when the
whole night was happening. If you guys remember just because
Andrew is not saying everything is that's >> one month
ago.
>> that panel was one month ago, right? >> No, it
wasn't. It was like four or five nights ago. Four nights ago.
>> Yeah, it was it was not that long ago. It was like less
than a week ago. >> Um
Oh, there's a reference to a panel where Rob gets into it with
counterpoints. That one was a month ago. That one was um like
two weeks ago. But the this one that just happened where they're
on the show, the late night show and they're leaving that show
to go over to Rob's that was like three four nights ago and Andrew
Wilson said he woke up in the morning and he tuned in and Rob
was like still laughing about this or something and then Andrew
did a video on >> Yeah. The the fallout between Rob and
Sarah first started from the panel that was a month ago, >> the
counterpoints one. Rob felt like she was not moderating well
and then I think people were talking him and she messaged him
unsolicited advice. But we'll get into that when we get to the
raw video. >> It was after that one. >> So I have
this rule, right?
>> Wait, what? >> I'm sorry. I'm saying it was after
that one. He went on for counterpoints. That's like the first
one. And then I think he went on a couple times after and I think
one or two panels after that
Unsolicited advice. Okay. Yeah, it's >> There's two of
them really.
The first is you put a knife in my back, you only ever get to
do it once.
That's the first rule. It's a good rule. I used to be like, ah,
you know, we can maybe work it out and and you know, but over
the over the years, I've just decided that um it's just too much
work and I'm too busy. Too I'm too busy.
And the second is if you're too stupid to get it, you're too
dangerous to work
Those are the two rules. Pretty easy, >> You're too stupid.
Now, the funny thing about this is that that's like very vague,
right? And I've watched a decent amount of this video already.
Pre-watched, actually pre-watched, and it's very funny once we
we'll we'll go through it. When what Andrew actually means here
is um very overt in a way that you wouldn't expect or or maybe
it's one of those things where it's like I don't know why he's
telling us this cuz when he says if you're too stupid to get
it, I think he's like basically implying, right?
And you guys can check me on this. My my understanding of this
video is he's basically going, "If Sarah isn't going to sweep
for my guys, if she's like not going to make sure that they're
not getting made fun of in her spaces, then I don't care to work
with her. Okay? I literally help you out all the time. You can't
even sweep. You can't even help my guys out. You can't even like
not let these people, you know, totally rob for no reason. Like,
you're not going to you're not going to step in. You're not going
to say anything." Yeah, [__] you. I think it's explicitly
we're building an ideological movement and if you're not willing
to be ideologically motivated and ide ideologically committed
with us then you is sort of what I'm getting from this video
as we go through it. All right. You don't get it entirely there,
but I think that's the direction he goes in. >> To get
it, then there's no point in working with you. And if you stick
a knife in my back, that's the end of it. Now, I don't ever do
the revenge thing. I never go for repercussions. I never do any
of that. I do the worst possible thing that you could ever do
to a person,
which is I uh just cut off all contact with them. That's it.
That's usually the worst possible thing you could ever do to
people who stick a knife in your back. So, that
usually
>> Now, that is a particularly bad thing when you feel
like that person derives their their income from you, right?
Like if if Andrew cuts somebody off and he feels like they rely
on him for income, he's also basically like firing that person,
right? >> It's a little different because I do think he
probably has people who he thinks are despicable who he just
he's not going to cut off because he's got benefits from them.
He's basically talking about allies, people he perceives as allies.
That's what he'll do. I think >> works the best for me.
Now, the original
how to lose friends and burn bridges
was a video I did about a year ago on Alex PWF who decided that
he was going to go to a panel that I was not on
and talked about me with uh with his friends on that panel when
I wasn't around.
felt like a pretty brutal betrayal of a guy who if you go and
sort his videos by most popular
his live streams.
Guess what you find? The exact same thing. A lot of people who
cut a nice hog
off of me who just can't help.
They just can't help themsel. And this is why I always say too,
you know, never trust an egirl.
Never ever trust an E. Because it's not even that they're malicious.
>> Wait, is he quoting Is he That's weird to Okay, >> no
E girls never. >> That's a weird quote to throw down given
him and Nick's past. I guess they're at peace now. That's a weird
It's a weird quote for me. You just don't get it and he can't
explain it to him. You can never explain it because they just
don't understand it. Now, the last message I sent to Sarah was
remember nepotism.
Nepotism is how you stay successful in this world. Nepotism is
how you stay success. They just don't understand.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. He doesn't. So,
he's saying he wants nepatism. Of course, ironically,
he is misunderstanding nepotism. He's describing cronyism. Okay.
Nepotism in fact means that you are related.
>> Uh, nepotism has built into its definition the fact
that you are related. The practice among those with power and
influence of favoring relatives, friends, or associates. Oh,
this has gotten added. It It absolutely used to mean No, it absolutely
used to mean relatives only. And cronyism is the idea of like
promoting your friends and
>> uh god damn it.
>> The appointment of friends and associates to positions
of authority. They're supposed to have different meanings and
this is like slowly over time getting eroded probably. >> Very
interesting. Every video of the on the raging tomato is privated.
Interesting. Uh, I was going to say like back in the day you
used to be so positive, so sure that like irregardless wasn't
a word until it continuously started to be said and they just
included it in the dictionary. >> Yeah. Yeah. Well, >> it's
easier to update it. >> Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Okay. I corrected, but it's no longer right definition here.
I listen, the Google definition popped up. I'm not I don't have
to cope. >> Yeah,
he meant it. We understand the way that he means it. So >> yeah,
I understood. But this is this is like the older definition.
Good jobs are unfair advantages for members of your own family.
It's he's he wants cronyism. He wants nepatism. Either one. He
wants advantages for the people in their circle. Hey, we're trying
to use this [__] that we're building to our own advantage.
If you're going to take the thing that I helped you build and
work against the people I'm also building up, then you're no
[__] good to me. And if you don't get it, get the
[__] out of here is what he he's actively saying,
"No, this is a cabal. No, we are cabaling. If you're not down
to cabal, then off. You're not an independent person. I didn't
go on your channel cuz you're independent. Off if you're not
ready to Cabal, which is pretty overt and pretty interesting
to hear." >> And I don't know how else I can explain it.
So, we're going to dive into this. Let me give you a little bit
of backstory here
because I didn't know exactly what was going on until I dove
in and learned what was going on. I'm going to give you a little
bit of backstory so that you understand what's happening here.
>> Okay. Now, I'm not going to be able to >> I'm
I'm going to dip cuz I I actually do feel like I'm one of those
women who doesn't get it. So, I'll talk to you guys maybe like
after this video or something. Okay. Bye. >> Bye-bye. So,
stop this systematically
in order to explain more backstory
to you. So, you're either going to be here at the beginning of
the stream and get it or you're not.
>> what what's happening here, what you're seeing is Rob
Norm, who is in a debate panel with Radical Coder, the Powder
Dusty, stupidest name ever, Nova Star, and it's moderated by
this. >> We're uh we're talking about Moody Morgan. We're
talking about um Andrew Wilson wants basically favorable, you
know, moderation, favorable opinions to be put forward about
the people he considers like close to him, a part of his political
movement, and he's spent time building up this raging tomato
person, and he feels like they were not
right? They were not fair to him or to Rob actually. Now, I don't
know if that's necessarily true, but h definitely he wants a
a bend towards them is what Andrew wants. >> Uh gentleman
here, Trippy. Okay, that's what's happening. That's what you're
looking at.
Now what happened is Rob, who is a worldclass debater,
literally worldclass debater, has been up against the best in
the world and beat them,
is a valued asset to the Crucible because, well, he has this
particular job that he's really good at.
as stupid leftist
to orbit and become dominant forces online. He catches them before
they can and beats them down into the ground where they belong
verbally.
That's what he does. And he's really
good at it.
Now, it's a pretty thankless except Pisco. I mean, Andrew is
going to say that I would say the fact that Rob can fight Pisco
to like a draw in a lot of cases or has in the past is probably
testament to his ability to debate and be super like headstrong
in debates in and of itself, right? The fact that Rob is taking
like a lawyer from this like prodigious school, okay, prestigious
school rather, this prodigious fellow from this prestigious school,
okay, and he's like equaling him in debates. That's already pretty
crazy given Rob's like background, his education, all of this
stuff, right? So, I I understand where Andrew is coming from
and probably for other people. I'm sure I'm sure Rob does actually
like demolish people,
Really
good at it.
Now, it's a pretty thankless job.
Pretty thankless job, but that's what he does. These pop their
head up and he plays whack-a-ole with them. They pop their head
up. Hey, I want to be a big lefty star. And Rob is right there
to smack their act right back down and says, "No, you're not.
No, you're not."
And absolutely savages them back into their stupid little hideyholes
from which they came
>> It's a very thankless job, but he's really good at it.
Really good at it.
And for that, Rob, we thank you. Now he I just really love how
like a bunch of basically every other debate circle is like,
"Guys, we're committed to the truth and we want to figure out
what's true and we want to like defend our ideas." And Andrew
Wilson's like, "No, if I help you, you better be on my side and
I'll destroy you. I'll bury you if you make yourself if you make
it seem like you're on my side and that you do not sweep for
my guys. You don't like give my guys preferential treatment,
I'll end you." Now, it's not quite that bad because there are
some there's like some there's definitely some things you could
argue the Raging tomato did wrong,
but
I think this is a bit overblown from what I've seen. Trump effect
a little bit. Yeah. The the idea is Okay, Dustin Suggs, the idea,
especially for anybody who's been in any sort of like right-wing
or race realist adjacent circle is like
people will tell you that you shouldn't be you shouldn't form
group biases like in groups. you shouldn't form these groups
and like advocate in favor of them against like all logic or
whatever, right? You shouldn't do like this white solidarity
thing. It's like not actually cool and then all of these other
groups formed their groups, right? There's like there's a bunch
of groups for every other race in the US. I'm telling you like
how these people think. That's probably how they see the online
debate space is something like we're like the guys as right-wingers
and we could pretend to be committed to ideological or not ideological
but uh intellectual purity. We could pretend to be committed
to only being pursuing the We could pretend to commit to only
pursuing the truth, but if we do that, we're going to lose to
all the people who just issue the truth to push their ideology.
And so, we're going to push our ideology,
right? That's I that's sort of what I'm reading into the things
he's saying. He decided since Rob is a popular streamer
and he actually has quite a large audience considering
uh how badly he's been blacklisted all over the internet. He
decided that he would go on and do yet another debate where radical
coder who's popping his head up for the purpose of some type
of prominence and he's doing what he does best which is to bash
them about the head and shoulders verbally and stuff them back
into their pole where they
In this particular exchange the beginning of this panel
Rob wanted to give these people a taste of their own
I had a bad feeling in how she moderated the last debate. Yeah.
Uh anyway, he wanted to give them a taste of their own
And so what he did on this particular panel is he wanted to demonstrate
for them that it's necessary to have people like him on worldclass
debaters who are prominent, know people, and have a good following.
uh that if you with those guys, right, your bread and butter
from most of these nontent makers, and what I mean by nontent
is they rely on other people 100% for all of their content. None
of them are standalone creators like myself or Rob.
Sure, we can rely on people for it, but we don't have to.
We can have people on the show, we don't need them. We can do
solo shows. We can do debates. It doesn't really matter. We're
just
awesome at what we do. show. >> okay. So, I agree with
this and and like nobody's going to say Andrew is wrong that
Rob is a bigger creator than everybody's on this panel, right?
Very obvious. I don't even know who I know who Radical Coder
is because he likes Aerodite and he's got really mad about some
of my coverage in the past. I've like seen him commenting on
YouTube streams about how much he sees about my content. That's
the only way I know who that is. And then the rest of these guys
are Oh, and he did the uh the DEI math. He was defending like
um like teachers trying to do DEI math in textbooks, right? Do
you remember like oh or DEI teaching approaches rather? Remember
like black kids if we could Yeah. CRT. Yeah. Like if we could
get black kids moving and like dancing and singing then maybe
they would better understand math. And it's like okay I you understand
this sounds like parody, right? Right. Right.
Anyway, so we that's where I know him from is he did a debate
like that with Destiny a long time ago. So the rest of them not
as big. I do get a little bit concerned where you you can say
this and it could be implied, but you should leave it implied
because you don't want to go on these panels and go like, "Oh
yeah, I expect absolute difference because I'm helping you out."
That's like not a good relationship to form. And I don't think
that's like really a part of Andrew or Rob's values, but he's
kind of saying it explicitly here in a way that makes me feel
odd. It just seems odd.
>> Back to the story at hand. Back to the story at hand.
to teach these guys a lesson about the moderator from Trippy
here. Rob decided that he would stay on the panel, mute himself,
right, and just allow these guys to continue with the boring
panel that they had planned and show them that without him, it
was not going to be a very good one. And well, he was right.
He was right.
Now, interestingly enough, why do I give a [__] about
this? Well, I don't I don't give a if this guy's a bad moderator.
I don't give a [__] if Rob No lost a debate or won
a debate. I don't give a >> Why is he saying it out loud?
It doesn't make any sense. It makes perfect sense. What are you
talking about? It doesn't make any sense.
You You don't think you could
How do you think How do you think Israel manufactured consent
for their campaign in Gaza and basically a ton of their actions
over the past like I don't know multiple decades? It's about
doing [__] like this, right? having people who are
interested in telling your side of the story and making sure
there aren't people interested in telling the other side of the
story like that this kind of uh group formation absolutely is
is a successful and and h how do you describe it? It happens
a lot. It happens basically everywhere. It happens usually by
implication, but it does happen overtly as well. It's just weird
when it happens overtly because normally that's
>> Give a about any of that because frankly it's none of
my business. >> Right. Rob can debate where he wants, who
he wants. Uh him coming to work for The Crucible. Uh that that
we had the deal up front that Rob can do whatever content he
wants, and I'm not going to interfere, and I never have.
Not my business. So, I don't care about any of that.
I don't give a about any of these people who are over here talking
mad as they send trolls after Rob after this debate.
I don't care about that either. only care about one thing, which
is this person here.
>> Uh, Victor Sharp, you're saying this like it's not a
decision. I believe it's an explicit decision from Andrew, right?
It is one of those things and we'll this all dovetales really
nicely with the Silly Serious video that we'll watch a little
bit later, but it is about
it's about the appearance of being correct, right? You'd be shocked
at how often being correct means dull and how being how having
the appearance of being correct means everything. Right, Andrew?
I've watched Andrew say things that are
and he looks totally confident. He looks totally correct. His
voice sounds correct. He has like the right posture. Um only
in one case and it had to do with economics. It wasn't like a
he's a all the time. I think he's a good debater. I think he's
a smart person. I just don't uh I just I've heard him be 100%
wrong completely and just sound all entirely correct. It's crazy
how effective it is. >> You may know her as Sarah the tomato.
>> Oh, he's uh dude, we could just do this. Let's just
turn the lows out. Hold on. How does this sound? Do you guys
get Is this low? Is my voice low now? We just >> Who honestly
the >> I'm talking about Sarah the raging tomato. Truth
is only has a channel which is beginning to rise to prominence
do 100,000%
to the Crucible and one Andrew Wilson.
>> That's it.
Nope.
100% due to >> Andrew is just coming out and saying here
that he thinks Sarah can't hack it without him. Now, is that
true? Do we know that for a fact? I wouldn't say we know that
for a fact, but he's he's out here saying it and he's out here,
you know, taking whatever whatever hand of charity he was extending.
He's clearly deciding to retract it. I can't talk with this cadence
without feeling kind of goofy and making things up to say. I
might have to go back to the regular
I might have to just go back. You sound underwater. Oh well,
I could just do the voice. If I just do the voice directly, it'll
sound better. >> Us. That's it.
not even in dispute that this is the case. Now, why is it that
Sarah would be on a panel while all of these other nontent maker
anonymous
idiots are sending trolls over to Rob's channel and participating
and contributing to that when she knows
how uh important Rob no is to the Crucible and how much of a
valued team member he is. I have no idea, but that was the stupidest
thing that she's probably ever done. >> So,
that is like correct in a technical sense, or you could defend
that interpretation from Andrew. It looked to me like Sarah joined
a late night thing
where somebody was streaming. They had gotten into a scuffle
with Rob. They were watching Rob's stream and a couple of the
people who were watching Rob's stream on this panel, it was on
this powder dusty guy stream, okay? They were all in like a a
Streamyard call together. A couple of the people dropped out
of the StreamYard call and called into Rob's stream and were
ostensibly trolling him, but also like having real debates with
him. So, I'm not totally sure. Rob pulled them in and argued
with them and kind of just like knocked them all down.
And I think Andrew didn't like that people were kind of trying
to make Rob seem like a local
and and Sarah was complicit as in not saying this is wrong or
not saying Rob was right or winning or defending Rob in any way.
So, we'll keep watching >> because what you don't do is
go a littlehead somebody else's panel >> and go after your
own people. That's the opposite of nepotism. It's a very stupid
move. Can all these people talk with impunity? Sure. Do I give
a
never commented on it before? Because frankly, they're fleas
on our ass. They're meaningless. Okay. totally meaningless people
on the internet and they've made a zero dent in society ever
with anybody. They've never made a single dent. This this idiot's
been streaming as long as I have. this one longer than me and
they've never made a single dent
except of course Rob who has done a lot
and been in some of the largest most brutal blood sport debates
which you could ever find online
he's been on Tim Pool he's been on massive shows right he's the
only one here who in the greater scheme of things even matters
that's it
and also
very close friends with me and he's an employee of the Crucible.
>> Yeah, Gregor Samson. We're going to watch Rob's video
after this. We're starting with the Andrew video cuz that's what
comes first chronologically, but we will go to the Rob video
after. >> Now, what what you're about to see is Sarah the
tomato here setting her feet on fire to warm up her hands. I
have no idea why she decided to do this.
You have no idea the opportunities which have been extended to
her through me, right? But it's my own fault. I take full responsibility
for all of this. So, here's Sarah's useful aspect of what she
does. She books me debates. That's it. I adhere to the moderation
of the debate
because that's what I do.
That's the relationship,
right? And I've always said for people who support us, we'll
support them. A lot of these very obscure channels get a lot
of subs and get a lot of cash because of that. I mean, a lot.
You don't bite the hand that feeds you. You don't come for the
very people who are at the forefront who provision you, make
it possible. She's about to have a big 20,000 sub party. Oh,
that's great. That's great. >> Uh, probably not now. I
believe she's lost like 2 or 3,000 subs. She's lost a lot of
subs. You're welcome.
My only business here is why it would be that she would be on
a panel that's not hers criticizing
and laughing as they send trolls to Rob Norse channel who we
spent significant amount of resources to grow and make
um let's see here
she hit let's just take a look at the analytics. She hit 20,000
subs, 20,0001 and then minus 2K the first night, - 400, - 800,
- 300. She privated all of her videos earlier
Okay,
so
these guys got a lot of pull. All right, and realistically, you'll
see Andrew isn't even necessarily criticizing her for stuff she
said. Andrew is criticizing her for being present. The fact that
she is there is what upsets Andrew and not like telling these
people it's wrong to do this or stop or whatever.
So Andrew is not even mad at her for for like things she said
or on Rob. He's he's actually like more mad that she was endorsing
this. No, she's in the she's in the StreamYard for the panel.
This is her down here. And then this is a panel that's reviewing
the VOD of Rob with like there's the powder dusty guys in here.
And then I actually don't know any of the other people, but then
there's Sarah as well. had enough of a force so that he could
play whack-a-ole with upand cominging leftists. So, let's dive
in and watch the complete kuruffle as this woman completely destroys
all working relationship with your truly forever
>> Well, I don't know. How should I say this, Star? >> Isn't
she doing debate con? Oh no. Oh, you're right. Oh my god. Oh,
how would we ever be able to coordinate debate con without her?
Manted will be taking over Debatecon. No problem.
We'll switch the coordination right to Manted.
That was a great opportunity
for Sarah.
Not for me. We got a great staff. My staff will take that over
in 5 seconds. We'll I'll pay her out to what I promised her for
debate con. Done. >> You should kick Rob off the panel.
>> I would. Uh, Andrew is like this is like quite cutting
or quite um like to go this level of nuclear is pretty crazy.
I I can understand a little bit of why he'd do it, right? But
he he like goes nuclear and he's like she has no talent. She's
not good for anything. I can replace her in two seconds. Like
it's it's like about as brutal as you could possibly be uh with
with anybody you're employing uh employing or professionally
associated with. It's crazy. >> I swear to God I would
actually
I would I would probably do, you know, and then close it probably
after. >> Unless somebody's going to take somebody's place,
>> unless somebody's going to give me an extraordinarily
high amount of money to drop Rob, that'd be great. It would go
to mom's medication. I think that's
So Tippy
asking so because Rob's not >> also I do wonder a little
bit if Andrew intentionally gets these names wrong or like cuz
to me I I can't tell if he's doing it intentionally to mess with
people cuz he keeps calling her Sarah the tomato. It's like you
got to know that's not the full name and then he calls this guy
Tippy. Are you is he dyslexic or is he being like insulting?
I'm not sure which. participating at this point in the panel.
Tippy doesn't exactly know what to do. He doesn't know if he
should drop Rob or not drop Rob. He's in quite the conundrum
here. Conundrum one. If he drops Rob, he's lost any potential
audience he might have because none of these have one. So, he's
trying to hold out. Tippy's trying to hold out. He's like, "Well,
maybe I can make a little bit of money from somebody at least,
and that way when I drop Rob, it won't be a complete bust." I
don't blame him. Isn't it funny though,
you know that I taught all of these channels, all of them, how
to even make money with their channels. I taught every one of
them either directly or indirectly, how to even make money with
their channels on YouTube. >> Feel like this is just Andrew
in a mob movie, right? And Sarah's like an Sarah's somebody they
think could have talked to the cops. The cops let her go. She
didn't necessarily talk to the cops, but Andrew's like, "Well,
we got to make it clear that if you even if you get let go, okay,
if if there's the appearance that you talked to the cops, we
got to take you out." And that's what he's doing, right? Like,
oh, you have the appearance. I I think somebody could argue that
you were being rude to Rob or you were trying to [__]
with Rob. Bye. If I ever get that implication, if people ever
complain to me about that, I will next you immediately,
>> No need. No need. I wouldn't want to step on Ryan Stone.
If if it's my turn to speak, let me know. Otherwise, >> you're
going to passive aggressively crash out.
>> Trippy, I would be happy to make it up to you and Nova
Star to come on and talk to you guys. I'll rate >> Rob
says to Trippy >> here. Trippy, I'll be happy to come back
on and make this up to you.
>> Wait, what did he say at the end though?
>> Started come on and talk to you guys. I'll raid
>> raid raid. He said raid. Okay. Rob says to Trippy here,
Trippy, I'll be happy to come back on and make this up to you.
Okay, I get it. This didn't work out. It's not necessarily your
fault. I'll come back and make it up to you. But these guys >> over
to your channel, everyone that's watching, no problem. But for
now, everyone needs to be educated in the fantastic wisdom of
Ryan. He clearly has so much to say. So, I'll just I'll sit in
the back until it's my turn to speak again. Did he raid them?
Go ahead. Just let me know. I doubt it. He's crying like a right
now. >> Now, you see these people on this panel are talking.
What you can't see is that this individual right down here is
Sarah the tomato. Not It's not that she's not saying anything.
It's that that soon she will just have to join in on the pylon
as they begin sending trolls over to Rob's channel after this.
So again, I think sending trolls here, meaning like the people
in this call, I don't think they were like, to be honest, I'm
not sure that they could manage much of a hate raid on Rob's
channel, but they were sending people over to Rob and then they
were joining to debate Rob. Well, I think Andrew goes over a
couple of them. >> Once again, I I guess I'll respond again.
Rob, as you can all tell, is not engaging. He is not demonstrating
that there is a governor who is refusing uh to follow a federal
court order. He's
uh he is not demonstrating that ICE >> up there together
oneonone to see if he >> he's not demonstrating
that I is incapable of carrying out >> their duties or
the police are incapable
willing to demonstrate their duties. He's not showing the courts
are not working. He's not showing to the to Little Rock. He's
>> People can't even afford non-stuttering internet. You
see how beautiful this stream is?
Isn't it gorgeous? It's crisp. Looks professional. His His background
graphic is like straight out of the 2016 streamer world, right?
It's like I It is It's okay. It's okay. >> Got great audio,
handsome host. It has everything you could ever want.
He's can't even seem to get a panel together that doesn't stutter
the entire time. just asserting that because of some bastardized
standard of the insurrection act that he has engaged with by
debating >> good man to stand behind a brother bros before
hoes simple how many times have I told you people how many times
I don't even give a Rob was 100% in the wrong I don't even care
if he was
when your boy gets up at the bar you get up with him >> I
do love I do love that it's you know he He fixes this by saying
Rob wasn't wrong, right? But it's pretty crazy that he's like,
"Yeah, even if Rob was completely wrong, I'd still do the same
thing." Okay, I I understand why he wants to stick by Rob. Okay,
they're close. They're friends. They've been friends for a long
time. They came up together. I totally get why he wants to stick
by Rob. I think you could do that. Maybe without destroying this
person, but you could you could also stick by Rob and say this
is unacceptable.
That's That's not so bad.
It don't even matter if there >> he's gone pretty far past
that >> in the wrong. Now he's not in the wrong. But even
if he was in the wrong, I don't care. We're in an ideological
war and we're not punching right.
It ain't happening.
much leftwing uh streamers. Uh he can now invoke the insurrection
act based on on that standard. A handsome host. Very silly, but
he if he doesn't want to engage, I mean, that's on him. Like
I I think it's a bad idea. Um,
>> it's kind of funny that all of the people who are
uh I don't know. I I don't have to really go into it. It's pretty
funny that he's like, "Oh, we're in an ideological war. We're
not punching right." It seems like that should concern someone,
right? That that there are right-wingers online who are content
creators who are all, you know, banding together. They're not
going to punch right. Seems like a lot of very smart people who
make a lot of money on the internet have decided that this is
the tactic you need to do, right? Hey, we need to group together.
We need to make sure we're like going the same direction, pulling
the same direction.
I just find it interesting >> and I think it's it's very
>> This is a convoluted explanation. Well, go to your channel
and tell your >> I also don't understand why. Wait, one
to who are you talking to? So, you're a Nazi. Are you responding
to Andrew? What about what Andrew said here means he's a >> five
viewers about it. >> Clear. It's a bad idea. It's going
to be as Dusty was explaining very well. Uh it's an escalation
and we're obviously going to see escalation. There's going to
be more and more people who are protesting. There's going to
be more people who are potentially even breaking laws in their
protesting or even engaging in violence and the police will likely
continue to crack down on that as they have been thankfully uh
because they are able >> blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah
the military
>> if he's never punching right I mean he's literally his
former name is big papa fascist I'm just curious why you think
he's why he's like anti-semitic in some
I I would just be I don't know I even seen it.
>> Okay, I'm taking off. Thanks for having >> Let
him up together. He's not listening >> Wait, no.
>> Cuz Rob's Cuz Rob's punking all of us and he's trolling
and he's being disrespectful and I don't know why any of you
are still taking it seriously.
>> That's right.
What Rob did was he gave you an object
All of you are nobodyies. And this isn't me being arrogant. I'm
going to state the objective truth. In the greater scheme of
things, I'm a nobody as well. In the larger scheme of things,
it's scalable.
Compared to many people like Steven Crowder, I'm a nobody. It's
all
But you're at the bottom of that scale. You people are at the
very bottom of that scale.
So, yes, while scalable, and I agree that it is.
Okay. What you did was you just kicked off the only person there
who even had a audience to even view any of you stupid. >> Power
trip much. Andrew will not stand for snarking on Rob. Okay. Any
of these people snarking on Rob, they they get taken out immediately.
Andrew Andrew don't accept no snark from anybody who's, you know,
getting money from his audience. All right. No snark allowed.
It says no snarking zone over here. talking about the you're
talking about. It's a good object lesson for you and how you
treat guests.
Don't with them, especially when they have the following that
you're counting on to make you the money, you stupid.
Now, this is troll number one, what you're seeing here, that
they sent over to troll Rob No. He's part of this panel verse
mafia, whatever the that is, and he has decided to come on and
troll Rob. And you'll see him make an appearance back on the
panel shortly. Why? While these people mock Rob as this is going
on. >> True event. >> I don't blame you. >> Anything
else? >> Is it because there's a dough boy behind >> No,
that looks like Eric Hartman. I don't think he's a dough boy.
>> Sorry. It was a one. >> You don't even know your
own stupid backgrounds and jokes, huh? >> I don't.
>> Strike three. >> So, you you have no uh >> like
these people are coming on to like on Rob and call him fat and
it's like I understand why Andrew wouldn't like that, right?
You don't want somebody you care about who you think is a good
debater to just get like mocked for no reason by people who you
like who you obviously help financially a huge amount. That's
he's basically like investing in Rob as an ideological ally and
investing in Sarah as an ideological ally and now Sarah he feels
like is trying to undercut Rob by participating in this. So,
I understand like on its on the surface why that would be the
case, why you could feel that way, but I think the whole purpose
of having like a panel that you have a favorable, you know, a
favorable relationship with is some kind of appearance of independence,
right? Rather than going, "No, I control you and you didn't help
me and you." That's usually why you would have like a smaller
panel that you want to have a good relationship with while not
having control over is because you want the appearance of some
level of independence. And he's just gone, "No, you're not independent.
I own you. [__] >> You have no advice as far
as >> I don't have any advice for >> Do you go out?
Do Do you Do you engage with protesters? Do you engage with people
like in the real world or is it just online? >> I ran for
Congress and you >> did you succeed? >> I did not.
And you ran >> I guess it's just
that it's you tried things and you failed. Did you think about
that? That makes you a failure. You look like you haven't tried
anything or failed at anything. That's what actual failure looks
like. Okay. Not getting up and making any effort at all. You
this guy. Okay. Also, BB Poison. I have this I sort of have this
feeling too, right? Where I think I think Andrew is undercutting
Rob a little bit. I think Rob has a good response after this.
I understand where Andrew is coming from, but I don't know if
he knows that this could be I think turned back against Rob and
made to make him look kind of like a [__]
Luckily for Rob, Rob can just go argue on his own,
right? He can. But
I don't know. Andrew is sort of stepping in here in a weird way.
>> Try, right? Cuz they could probably >> I bet I
bet you do great. I bet you do. Where do you live by the way?
>> There's quite the setup.
Waiting for her to chime in. Anytime to give a defense here
or even better, just not be a part of a panel coming after uh
Rob Noir.
That would be good too. Just you could try that. You could try
just not You know what? You don't even have to agree or disagree.
You could just do what no one has ever successfully done in their
entire life. You could just shut your mouth. You could just do
that. She's not going to be able to help herself though. You'll
see as as stupid here decides to >> There's a lot more
than they do to get >> but you can hear this this cackling
laughter and you'll never guess who it's coming from. >> This
me royally every day for a long time until recently. So, you
know, ever since I discovered your content >> life, is
that what you call him?
>> Who? My boyfriend. >> Yeah. Depends on the day,
you know.
>> Called Rob No. And he wants me to be called Destiny.
I call him Rob. Yeah. >> Gee, listen to that laugh. Who's
that? >> Why? This guy sounds like asleep, like half asleep
as he's calling into this >> Coming from this me royally
every day for a long time until recently. So, you know, ever
since I discovered your >> life, is that what you call
him?
>> Who? My boyfriend. >> Yeah. Depends on the day,
you know. Sometimes different names called Called Rob No. And
he wants me to be called
I call him Rob. Yeah. That's it.
>> So, Andrew, if you in case you missed it, Andrew is
upset that Sarah is laughing at this guy like trying to mock
Rob and failing. Right.
That's She hasn't said anything, but she does
>> What is she laughing at? the guy who made a joke about
his boyfriend being Rob no and him being Destiny or something
implying Rob has a gay obsession with Destiny. I think I think
that's the joke. He also might she also might be laughing at
Rob laughing at this guy. Like it might be funny because it's
a bad joke and Rob is pointing that >> Yeah. Okay. >> Yeah.
I'm not I'm not sure. >> What an optics nightmare.
It just continues to get worse and worse and worse. Watch for
yourself.
>> Still don't know what's going on. >> What's that?
Now, I just realized I left because I'm a woman and I don't get
it and I'm back and I still don't get it. But it's okay. I'm
going to stay this
>> Well, guess what?
I know that there are going to be people who say, "Why don't
you bring Sarah up to give her side of things? Why didn't she
bring Rob up to give his?" She can sit and suffer and watch just
like he had to wake up and suffer and watch her knife him right
in the back on a panel that it was none of her business. Had
nothing to do. It wasn't her show.
Staying on with these stupid panel verse idiots.
Nobody's so gay about Rob. I I know that he's like defending
Rob like overdefending Rob here. There's some argument for why
you do this, right? like the the implication that if you're not
going to defend my guys later on, if you're going to just be
like a if you're going to be a bump on a log when people are
trying to like ruin the reputation of one of my friends, I'll
cut you off completely. I understand why sending that message
could feel important. As BB Poison said, I don't know if this
is the right way to do it or if this looks quite the way they
expect. It certainly can be twisted in a way that doesn't seem
favorable, but I don't know, maybe he thought about all that
when he did the stream. This is just a live stream he did shortly
after this happening. He just did a long live stream, I think
two hours or something on this content. I think these are just
the cuts that they wanted to put in the video.
>> He's throwing his weight, right? Because she won't be
the unbiased moderator that you kind of expect on a panel like
this. >> Well, no, he she's not moderating on that. This
is just like an after hours >> but you are expected whether
it's on stream or off >> to defend Rob if you're going
to take Yeah. If you're >> to be neutral, right? If you're
>> neutral or Yeah. >> Yeah. If you're on a panel
uh or on a stream off of this laughing at him, why would anybody
look to you to be like an unbiased moderator? >> Or not
even just that, it's why would I be paying you? Like that's my
friend. You are you are literally on a panel laughing at my friend.
I pay you money. Like it's it it just makes me look like a I
feel like stupid for supporting you. Like I want you to give
him a fair shake. I'm sure. But I don't know. Andrew certainly
sticks away from pointing out where they're not giving Rob or
where where she's like not giving Rob a fair shake. I feel like
it's just like these people are and she's kind of quietly sitting
there andor laughing and sort of being >> a like slightly
biased against him, but not even in a horrible way. >> I
think it's just like if I this is just a way it's like a mafia
thing, right? Where if you give me the impression that you're
not on my side, I'm not having you a part of my team. [__]
you. Is what I think he's doing here.
Like I think I think he's just trying to cut this person's legs
out to let other people know in the future. You [__]
with Andrew Wilson,
you'll get taken out or if you [__] with Andrew Wilson
while he pays you, that won't keep happening. I I think is broadly
what he's trying to go for. Um I don't know if it's going to
be effective to keep watching cuz I I now that I've seen this
video, I feel like now I've got a lot more context for Rob Norris
cuz when I first watched the Rob stream, I didn't have the context
of Andrew statements at all. So now I'm getting all of Andrews
and then we can go and watch Rob's after this and it'll be a
lot more informed I think. >> Cam up. They're nobody. Chuckle
while they send trolls over to try to make an optical spectacle
of Rob Noir. Here's a dirty secret.
Rob's a better debater than I am. Wow. >> Not with philosophy.
>> You don't expect that to come out of somebody who has
like a debate university, right?
>> Yeah. He's And I'm I'm not even saying that to mock
him. I'm saying he's glazing Rob because he he wants people to
respect Rob. He feels like I think >> man, there might
be multiple things going on here. >> He's like fixing whatever
he thinks Sarah could have possibly done to his investment, right?
>> Well, and he's um I think he's basically saying that
if you guys think it's okay to treat Rob like he's a if you Sorry,
I'm looking away from the mic while I'm speaking. Um if you guys
think it's okay to treat Rob as a joke, it's not. And let me
make it very clear, it is. Rob is not a joke. >> All of
you people are jokes. And if you're going to treat Rob like he's
a joke, I'll show you what you are. I'll put you in your place.
>> I think that's what he's also there's another like layer
of that. Like I again it's like kind of the same message, but
>> it's it's that they're they're laughing. They're trying
to make snide remarks. So this guy's coming on to call him fat.
And it's like >> And there's nothing worse than your whole
debate tactic is you're not going to engage with the argument.
You're not going to answer any question. You just want to say
you're fat. >> Yeah. Yeah, exactly. >> And now everyone's
going to burn this try to burn this dude's reputation and just
try to emotionally provoke him.
For what?
>> For like a couple likes. Yeah. And like Yeah. So basically
he feel I think he feels that that's what they're doing. These
people are like useless. They're just working against him and
his movement by trying to hurt Rob's reputation and somebody
in his movement is there kind of complicit >> for no reason.
>> For no reason. Like no benefit to her. Yeah. Yep.
>> But on normative political issues,
Rob's the best I've ever seen.
Nobody's even close. And he's front and center. He's got his
face out there for everybody to ridicule.
He's taken on the biggest debates you can imagine. And he's been
ridiculed over and over and over again, blacklisted, everything
else.
>> And this Durant,
it's not for the panover verse. I think what you guys would know
this as is Discord queens. You guys understand Discord queens.
You're in a Discord. There's a woman or sometimes an E boy who
gets the most attention and they can take over an entire Discord
and you just lost you lost that community to this person having
nothing but time to type and reply to every person in that Discord.
They've built up a rapport and a personal relationship with every
individual in that discord.
>> And that's no longer your comm. You don't have the time
of day to go in there and undo whatever reputation damage that
they've done to you cuz they have endless time. These people
who will sit on streams and and spend time just like doing this
to Rob, these are like
panel queens. M I could see it being something similar that >> it
feels like there's some sort of connection where you you actually
you do have to squash this as soon as you see it because you
can't possibly go down the rabbit hole of continuously like fixing
your reputation against this.
>> Sure. And in this case he sees it happening to Rob.
I like there's something similar there that these people don't
have a lot going on. They don't have like a lot to lose and they
are attacking Rob's reputation over like not even a lot. Like
they're they're just going at Rob's reputation and Andrew is
probably like, "Oh, you have to protect your I I think some of
this might be a lesson for Rob, too. I think Andrew probably
feels like you have to pro protect your reputation, Rob, and
you're not doing it effectively." I think part of this is a lesson
for Rob as much as it is for for Sarah. >> Yeah. I'm not
even sure if it's his reputation. It's like putting him in a
spiral where
you want to have these political debates. We're just going to
we're going to do like a troll trigger fest.
We're going to make it so that you can't have any like uh intelligible
conversation.
Like that's what you think these people are doing. >> We're
just going to do WWE on you and everybody who would be following
you for politics is soon going to walk away from >> cuz
we're never going to let you talk about politics. >> Well,
and that's one of the things that Rob did. Yeah. And I'm sure
this could happen, right? You don't want all of your callins
to just be a total joke. >> So, yeah, that could be if
they're all just gonna call in and clown him and everyone's gonna
participate. It just looks it's super bad optics. >> Yeah.
Like Rob even taking some of these like if I just get the feeling
that somebody that's why I always ask people if you want to call
in like tell me what your disagreement is and we're going to
stick to that because if you want to just talk to me about whatever
you just want to like talk or something I don't care to have
a conversation with you. Go do that somewhere where they care.
>> And some of the comments that I saw is like oh Rob can't
handle getting called fat. That's the problem. He can handle
it and he can roll in the mud and that's exactly what they're
looking for.
>> Got you. >> Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. And there is
some amount of like it's all Yeah. Like you said, all the serious
political viewers watching this, people who come to him for serious
politics. And if he's just going to take Collins and these people
are just going to waste his time, better to just cut it off entirely.
Yeah. >> Yeah. 100%. >> Stupid. What a stupid dude.
This stupid Yeah. In a philosophical debate, I would just completely
rip Rob's face off and he knows it.
But on normative politics,
unless he's doing the libertarian,
okay, then he's going to have trouble.
But he's the best. He's the best and he's a great commentator.
And by the way, I also proudly
call him one of my best friends. He's one of my best friends.
Like this guy has been,
you can't even imagine how kind this man is behind the scenes,
especially to yours truly and my family and especially when we
were in our time of need.
There was Rob. >> I agree with this. Rob is not
>> That's uh that's another reason I think Andrew is is
doing this. And it's nice that he's not even he's not even like
trying to hide it. He's like literally I just like this guy more
than you. You're going to hurt my friend. I'm I'm cut your head
off
for my friend. Yeah. Your head's gone. Bye.
You don't make new Rob Nor. I'm never going to be able to sit
down with a person and over the years mold them into a brand
new Robnor.
He's not replaceable. All these idiots, nobody's ever going to
know who the they are ever. They stream to three to seven to
10 people if they're lucky. And that's usually from other panel
verse
They all just watch each other's
It's the most pathetic display that you've ever seen. Rob No
is not replaceable. He is not a person who can be replaced. You
don't get to make a new
>> That's why I just laugh at him. I don't
know. You know what though? This is what I mean, dude. They're
trying to stop the
>> I know. All right, man. Thanks. >> Hey, don't
listen, bro. They're trying to stop the cook. >> Well,
thank you, man. It's >> Bro, you're a fake and I hope you
recognize that. >> There we go. Another troll sent over
by the all powerful panelvers.
>> No, we can.
>> Now, mind you, they're watching this
They're watching this live, sending their trolls. >> Sorry,
this super chat. This is for staying a late to give us bonus
content. Thanks for being willing to interact with the drunk
drug adult and mentally
cuz Rob made a money. Rob made like 800 bucks, 900 bucks on this
stream, right? You see his his super chat goal is at $800 for
the stream
over so that they can make live commentary to try to humiliate
my good friend Rob no.
Have you heard a single peep in his defense by Sarah the tomato?
>> Single peep. And by the way, even if she didn't want
to speak up to defend our good friend Rob Nor.
>> She could have just not been there. >> Here's
the thing that's hilarious. I'm just going to point this out,
right? Anybody can do Sarah's job. Anybody can reach out who
has a channel, right? who wants to book debates
and invite me to a a one v one debate with somebody who I'm interested
in debating and I'll go debate there. I'm not particular.
Sarah's always been replaceable. >> He not particular.
>> That's what's hilarious. She's always been replaceable.
Rob no, he's not
He can't be replaced.
>> Bob Kger. >> He's one of the best that there is
at what he does.
I'm not going to find another Rob. Sarah are growing on trees.
Yeah. You just walk outside.
>> There's just every opportunity there to say growing
on vines, man.
Like, why not? Why would you say grow tomatoes? Vines. >> Tomato
tree. >> There's not a pick them like they're apples. They're
everywhere. >> You guys saw his disappointed face. For
a moment, he thought I thought there was tomato trees.
>> Wait, what did you find for later? Hold on. What did
What did this guy find for later? is Rob Nor's insane straw man
debate. I don't >> there's a million different panel hosts
who are out there. A gazillion in fact. And again, I don't even
have anything against any of these people. Not a single one of
them.
Why? They're not affiliated with us. They're not uh they're not
people of great import who I respect, right? I don't give a what
they say. I don't care if Powder Dusty does a stream tomorrow
talking about me all day. I'll still go on a show and do a debate.
I don't even care about that. Don't care at all. BB Poison. What
is wrong with watching right-wing debate broke back mountain?
Okay, you got a problem here? This is true love and you're trying
to stand in the way and I think that says a lot about you and
your inability to find true love. Okay, that's that's what I
think.
Sorry, did I cut you off, Jerry? >> No, not the point.
>> Point is is that you don't go out of your way.
>> I I shouldn't cheapen it. I think they're very close
friends. I'm I don't actually think it's gay to say this guy's
my very good friend. Okay, that's just a joke. >> To join
in a panel with nobody's like this and troll a channel like Rob
Norris, talk a bunch of about him with these people when all
of your bills are being paid by the crucible. You >> go
back in. >> The rage just comes up.
You're going to go You're going to go talk about Rob Norwin.
All your bills are paid by the crucible. You >> Why did
it get cut there? What else did he say? We missed the rest of
the rage
>> to join in a panel with nobody's like this and troll
a channel like Rob Nors talk a bunch of about him with these
people when all of your bills are being paid by the crucible
you
back in and dusty. Look at that. >> I don't know why I
cut I do have I think I think somebody re-uploaded like Andrew's
full VOD more or less. I could go try to find that. I saw some
channel did that. We could go see. We can find >> There
he is. How's your boys doing, man? >> Man, they were funny.
They're the best part of the show. >> Where are you? Did
you watch a lot? >> Uh, I watched a little bit. Uh,
>> well, I watched I watched when people went over basically
watch over. >> You guys are great. That's it. You just
breath. Yeah, we're great. >> Well, we're great.
This audience,
this audience is paying this woman's bills. Not her audience.
This audience is paying her goddamn bills. This one
go after Rob nor
you.
She didn't just cross a line. She gleefully took a running long
jump over it. No, >> I bet those
>> Does it feel >> Watch It just keeps getting worse.
You'll see. It just keeps getting worse and worse. >> Does
it feel bad getting blown out in debates all the time of being
worthless? >> Bro, you're kidding.
>> you look Yeah, that's not what happened. Now, the powder
dusty, who's on this panel currently, is live again with Rob,
right? They're continuing the trolling. >> You know, that's
not what happened. >> That's absolutely the one-on-one
discussion we had, you weren't even
>> You know it. You know it.
>> No, you're coping. You know that's true. >> You're
coping so hard. >> What are you talking about? I'm not
coping at all. >> Every time Every time I've been in a
debate with you, you have either rage quit or tried to rage quit.
Dude, Radical Voter is the best debater I've ever seen. He crushed
me, but I you up. You know, it's >> I mean, you're you're
being sarcastic, but you
ask
>> the guy that they sent over to troll Rob now popping
up on this panel. That's really weird.
It was like there was some kind of coordinated effort here because
there was to try to >> Well, I think these guys, correct
me if I'm wrong, we watched a little bit of this. I believe they
just had these people coming in and out. Like people who were
sitting here who were part of like this actual panel were going
over to try to call into Rob's show. Like they were like, "Oh,
Rob will have you on. Yeah, go go go." Like I we watched that
happen back and forth. It's not like again, you could say this
is like a hate raid and he is saying they're sending them over.
It's a little different than just like saying, "Hey, everybody
should go with Rob." It's like, "Oh yeah, Rob will take you on."
It's kind of similar, but it's
Yeah. I just think it's the tone that they're taking that is
more offensive than anything else. Like that they're trying to
make a joke out of Rob. Right. If you're Andrew, hold on. I got
it. >> A bunch of about him with these people when all
of your bills are being paid by the Crucible. You project Vopod
for 10 says, "I've got a flat. I've got
that was it. He just got mad and said >> and then read
a super chat. >> And then read a super chat. to optically
make Rob no look bad cuz there was. It >> almost seems
like Sarah's participating in this because she is. >> Need
to go back and see when you went in there again last time. >> Well,
I want to be the bigger person here and say that we got smoked,
y'all. We got to our losses on the chest. It's true. Even I I
don't know anything about the guy. I'll be I'll be fair here.
I just know that he's like a standard conservative. But, uh,
Ortho pretty bad showing. The other guy, what's the guy with
the hat? Really bad. I mean, that was following that was just
like I was so secondhand embarrassed. I wanted to cry. But we
can do better next time. >> We're going to win in the song
Olympics.
>> I wasn't I wasn't there to I wasn't there to troll him.
Like I genuinely
am annoyed.
>> Like I'm genuinely annoyed with him. >> Everybody
did great. Um it was actually funny as and uh
>> guys guys you all did fantastic. Okay, you all did great.
Rob's totally owned right now. Rob's completely owned. We actually
totally won.
Meanwhile,
Meanwhile, his friend Sarah's channel not in a winning mood.
Okay. This this dusty guy might have won, but seems to have come
at a cost that he's not
>> you know, it's funny. They went and trolled him. It
was It was hilarious.
>> Act like a >> Oh, you know what, Kyio? You just
made me realize that this is another piece of this, right? I
think is dude just the just the vibes of like this panel where
almost none of them have anything useful to say like they're
they're not being funny. They're not really doing anything interesting.
Like it makes you think, okay, well maybe I'm not being intellectually
honest, but these people all suck. They suck so badly that I
want to cut all of this off now forever. Like anybody who thinks
it's worth it to spend your time around these people, these are
already people who are not worthy of being in my presence, Rob's
presence, like they're they're just so um their aura is so bad
that it's just like get them all out of here. We actually need
to cut this whole thing >> Well,
people will come around and like validate
sort of doing panels like this, right? I think Rob says he went
on one for the first time cuz he wanted to confront uh Counter
Points and Counter Points was on the panel. So he was able to
call in or whatever, join for the after panel and that's when
he got to talk to Conor and then he had people in his audience
telling him to go back to the panel. Go back to the panel. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And then Yeah. That's in Rob's video in a little
bit. He's going to describe that how his audience always wants
to push him to go on these >> Like what is why is radical
coder uh debating here? It this just seems like really unproductive.
>> Jesus. Okay. Just because rad just because radical coders
there.
>> Well, he I I met that dude at one of the canvasing events.
So, I just I assume that certain people are like trying to be
productive with their like engagement in politics. >> Oh,
like why is he debating on the on the show? >> That's what
you meant. Oh, that's not true. Sorry. The way you set that up,
just so you know, the way that sounded to me and I think everybody
else was radical coders there. Oh, this is a waste of everybody's
time. >> No, no. >> So, that was how that came off.
>> It felt like a waste. It would be a waste of his time,
right? if he puts like a lot of thought and effort into >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. >> some of the [__] that he's pushing.
I don't understand it. >> I knew that you'd met him before
and like had no problems with him. So, I just I was like, "Oh,
you just said something." I'm like, "Oh, you want to >> No,
I have problems with his ideas about
>> Sure. Sure. Everybody does. >> Personally, I don't
have a problem with >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. >> Like
a joke get treated like a joke. >> Well, I think >> uh
we watched a little bit of Rob's video. Yeah. earlier like before
the stream I I listened to some of this Andrew one while I was
driving around today doing errands. >> This is what happens
uh when people with the panel verse that way, right? If you're
not a panel verse person and you come in and you try to put the
panel >> who's this talking?
>> So Andrew zaps all of the context out of this. I think
this is the one place where Sarah is valid. Maybe you should
argue that Sarah shouldn't be saying this on this panel, but
Rob, not with the panel. The way she said it sounds egotistical.
It sounds bad. She's like kind of hurting her own case here.
But when we get to Rob's video, he'll go through the actual thing
that led her to like think this. And Rob kind of egoed. Rob kind
of egoed her pretty hard in a way that she could never have taken
and had any credibility
>> because what is she talking about? I've seen Rob on
panels for like over five
>> I just meant Yeah. >> Like where is she coming
off? Like giving somebody Oh,
>> you you've just started coming on my stream and on my
panels. You must not really know what panels are like. Like I
don't I don't think so. I actually think a lot of people do.
>> When it's like, okay, what actually happened was, you
know, Rob Rob was you five years ago running panels like the
Crucible panels, right? Rob spent time. No, Rob never ran them.
He never ran >> Yeah, he definitely ran them. >> Rob
no, >> I know for a fact Rob ran them because I I'm almost
positive that one time when I went to go hop on a call-in stream
to go I was going to go I think press Destiny when he was on
a Crucible stream. Rob was the guy in the waiting room who was
like, "Hey, what do you want to ask a question about?" >> Oh,
I didn't I didn't know that. I >> almost Oh, wait. Rob
might have been in there, too. Rob was No, but Rob was the moderator.
No, sorry. It was somebody else who was the guy in the calling
stream, but I was like messaging Rob trying to get I'm like,
"Bro, make this point. make this point. >> I feel like
Rob knows what he's doing here because I feel like Rob has done
this exact thing before and that's why like for the Dylan Burns
the hippie-dippy panels I I'm sorry he made it clear he uh stood
his ground and those people stopped attacking conservatives if
they ever wanted Rob and his people to come on those panels because
this was around a time on Twitch
>> it's like they wanted to have these panels where you
get conservatives and you get progressives and they would debate,
but then the progressives would report all of the conservative
channels
>> even though they had topics that would
>> like don't have
debates and then you report all the people who take the other
side of the debate because their ideas are problematic.
>> Well, so I I feel like Rob knows what he's doing. He's
being very firm from this from the jump with her like, "Hey,
you could do this or it could be that."
maybe she she's just acting like, "Oh, this must be his first
time in this rodeo." I don't think so. >> I thought maybe
I do think we'll we'll get to it cuz there's one part where Rob
actually steps over the line. I think he's totally inc I think
he's totally >> But we do have to we have to wait and we'll
get there eventually cuz Rob I I know Rob covers it in his video.
I don't know if Andrew covers it here. But this sort of this
sentiment like, "Oh, Rob tried to like control something he shouldn't
have." I think that's correct. I think the way she said it seemed
to imply some ego that I don't think I don't know if there's
like a ton of ego there. I think Yeah, we we'll just have to
get to it. I don't want to spoil it, though. So why >> that's
keep in mind
a lot of conservatives or a lot of people who have opinions that
the majority of the panel host audience don't like have been
on the the receiving end of like a brig brigade against their
channel or something like that. >> Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure.
And well the the other thing is is I do think there's something
to Sarah doesn't really step in as a mod very often even when
people are yelling over each other. So Rob doesn't like that.
Rob likes to people,
but at the same time, I've actually moderated Rob's debates before
and I think sometimes he can want to talk and he wants to get
his ideas out and he wants to interrupt us sometimes and he doesn't
like >> I have to say sometimes Rob will cut people off.
Yes. >> And and like he he really acts like it's like a
sin when it happens to him and I'm like, "Bro, you how do you
how do you be you and like get this mad about getting cut off
sometimes is a little a little much." with the panel verse. >> Who's
this talking?
Why, that's Sarah the tomato talking. Let's make sure we don't
miss a second. >> Troll him. Like, I genuinely
>> woman, give me another drink, please. >> I'm annoyed.
>> Like, I'm genuinely annoyed with him. >> Everybody
did great.
>> I'm not even going to attempt that. That would not go
well for me on the street. >> Um, it was actually funny
as
>> That's different, though. Andrew doesn't co-ho Andrew
didn't like meet his wife by co-hosting. It's different. >> And
uh >> very different. >> Yeah. Act like a like a
joke. Get treated like a joke. >> I'm saying we're peers.
I can't do the thing where I'm like go do this. >> If we
if we met like
just casually. >> Yeah. If we met and I had Andrew's beliefs.
Yeah. I'd be fine with that. >> And you had Oh, so so it's
more than just different. You also don't have his beliefs.
You You left that part out. >> You're going to You're going
to make me say the thing that he just said. That's how this gonna
end. Okay.
>> I'm a woman and I just hear like glass shatter over
my head and then the stream will go dead. Okay. It's be over.
>> Rob acts like a joke. He gets treated like a joke.
The only person who's on any of these panels who's not a joke,
who's had real life effects in the world.
The only person who's made any sort of dent in the culture war
at all. The only one who's ever done anything.
He's the joke.
All of these no cam, no-name, nobodyies, they are the successful
people you see.
>> Well, I think this is what happens uh when people with
the panel verse that >> Sarah says this is what happens
when people with the panel verse, >> right? If you're not
a panel verse person and you come in and you try to with the
panel verse people like they will all band together
like you just can't
do that. You just can't you can't go around to panelver verse
shows
and flip out on hosts and get mad at hosts or with host shows
and do that kind of stuff and then expect everyone to turn and
look at you and be like, "Oh yeah, come on back." You know, >> bring
me a shot, please. >> Yeah, that
>> that sounds like
she views the other people on her show or her audience like her
white night sim. You can't just come here and disrespect me and
think that the panel verse is going to let you do that. >> Well,
I don't think she was the one who was disrespected, right? It's
the trippy guy disrespected >> to the host. >> Yeah,
to the hosts, but Rob wasn't being like as disrespectful on her
panel, right? Rob was mad that she wasn't moderating, but I don't
I think and he does comment on it, but it might be after this
stream. >> Defending
that other dude. >> No, she's she's mad at Rob, but yeah,
she's defending the other host. She's saying you can't be this
way. And I think she feels that way a little bit in that Rob
kind of went at her for being a moderator when he kept getting
cut off by counterpoints. So it's probably some lingering annoyance
at Rob. >> What did Rob do to this dude? >> Rob left
the Trippy Guy. So the original video that the original debate
on the insurrection act >> was on the Trippycast guys channel.
>> So it was him and then some random woman was hosting.
>> Wait, that's >> Sarah wasn't there. >> That's
with the host or something. That's like uh >> when Rob
like leaves or >> when he mutes and then he leaves. That's
part of the content. >> Oh my god. >> Part of the
content. Yeah. >> I kicked this o out. This person rage
quits the panel. That's like part of it. >> It could be.
Yeah. Could be. >> That's the name of the game.
>> Sure. These people like to think they're more serious
sometimes that that's not like But yes, it is the name of the
game. And yeah, I think this whole thing could be if this if
Andrew hadn't come out out and just like cut her head off. Totally.
This could have just been good content for all of them. I think
I told I told Jerry before this Andrew video came out, before
Andrew had reacted, I was like, "This might just be Kayfab. They
might just be doing this to like draw a bunch of viewers in and
then they'll like all have like a big blow up on Sarah's channel
and she'll grow even more." Like, you know what I mean? Like
a big like heated like eight person [__] flinging
debate. >> Maybe it still will. >> Maybe. But I I
thought it was Kayfabe and then I looked at the like Sarah's
channel analytics and how she privated all of her videos. She's
like no views on any videos now. And I'm like, "Oh, never mind.
That's not what this is at >> Priving must mean that she's
worried about them getting reported. >> Yeah, I think so.
Yeah,
that would be why you report is you have like a what you perceive
to be a brigade coming in.
>> that's Sarah. Her her mic is showing you stupid look.
Oh, whose audio box is that? Like I think I think he doesn't
know the power >> Yeah, that's Sarah. You stupid idiot.
>> Kiss you. [__] your little teeny teeny teeny
teeny tiny little panel. You
>> Jesus
you. Let's listen to it again. >> You come in and you try
to with the panel verse people. >> No, you try to with
the panel verse people. Oh no, not the panel first people who
I've blown out a million
>> Like they will all band together. >> Well, I agree.
She's right. Listen to the last part >> You come in and
you try to with the panel verse people like they will all band
together. >> You come in though and you try to with the
crucible and we all band together
>> Like you just can't do that. You just can't you can't
go around to panel verse shows
and flip out on hosts and get mad at hosts or with host show.
>> We've got like a whole Andrew
I've got like a whole Andrew rant here that I kind of want to
catch that isn't in this video. >> Well, yeah. Yeah. So,
this is from like a two-hour stream and this is the highlights
out of the 2-hour stream. >> Okay. And I think there's
pieces of this
where I do want to go back and watch now or I do want to go back.
I'm like looking through his um
his transcript and I think I do want to go watch it a little
bit more before we go to the Rob video. So I'll keep going with
this >> and do that kind of stuff. Expect everyone to turn
and look at you and be like, "Oh yeah, come on back." You know,
like I think I think
I think he doesn't know the power of the panel verse. I think
he doesn't know the power of the panel verse.
What part of the crucible takes care of its own people are we
not understanding here? We take care of our own people.
You know where you're never going to catch me
on oppositional panels
talking
about Rob no.
That's literally that is literally the sacrilege here. you went
on some panel with like this guy's a liberal and a couple of
these people who came on were liberals or like counterpoints
conservatives like actual conservatives. You're one of these
two groups, right? That's not our that's not our people. You
go on on one of these panels with with one of those two groups
and you talk about Rob you
which just seems like it's crazy that it's that overt
me. Not that it's like wrong. Andrew Wilson's welcome to run
his business however he likes. I just thought it was very interesting
for him to go that aggro. >> Even worse, because it's a
sneak attack and it's going after somebody that they think is
somebody that they can target and attempt to humiliate in order
to bring the light of the crucible down in order to make the
Crucible look bad. So, they go after what they consider the weak
link,
the guy who does have a public persona who's affiliated with
the Crucible because he's employed by us. By the way, best decision
I ever made was employing that guy. Best one I ever made.
>> We get it. You love Rob No. Okay, we get it. You want
to kiss Rob No. Stop. Stop liking Rob No so much. Okay. All right.
This is uh a little bit later in that. I might want to go look
over this whole
I I kind of now now that I see that I've got the whole thing
like he can look at all the callins to Rob's stream and now I
kind of want to go and look and see if he watches that counterpoints
fan come in and debate Rob no. I do want to see >> Oh,
Quimman loves that guy. >> Yeah, I I just want to see that.
>> Yeah. And he's trying to, you know, plate as best as
he can to everyone on board. Uh, but Rob, you know, being given
an opportunity. Okay, I can mitigate with a two-minute timer.
And then Rob is still like now he's not even taking it seriously.
Now he's just being >> Now she's a lawyer. Exactly. >> Honestly,
that moment. >> Oh, wait. So way more. She actually she
actually talked a little bit more later on. Did Queen fall asleep?
I'm guessing he's just playing Digimon or something. >> I'm
guessing actually also it's possible sometimes when he wants
to cover stuff on his stream the next day, he doesn't want to
comment on it here. He wants to hold his his comments so that
he can give it his commentary on his own own >> He's definitely
game. >> It's definitely Digimon. If he if he wasn't just
playing Digimon, if he'd left his computer, he would have left.
If he is just playing a game where he has to have both hands
there, then he just can't minimize and unmute right >> Chick
has rad in tens of thousands of dollars in a single month because
of us. All you have to do is shut up. Just shut up and book debates.
No one cares about your great inputs. No one cares about No,
let Sarah's insights. Just shut up and book the debate. Shut
the [__] up and book the debate. You ready? Here's
the secret to your success.
Right. The secret, the whole secret. Shut the up. Book the debate.
Be fair when you moderate it. Repeat after me. Step one, shut
the up. Step two, book the debate.
>> You guys get why I can't do panels.
>> Uh because you think Andrew Wilson is going to say this.
Do you think I'll say this? You think somebody else is going
to say this about you? >> No, I'm not worried about you
guys saying it. I I don't know how to shut >> Oh, well,
I could I could never have said that just now. So, just to be
>> I am very fair, mind you.
>> Step three, give fair moderation.
>> That's it. >> Who else could have defended Adam
and Sitch? I'm like the fairest. >> Okay. No, that's,
you know, that's true. >> Step two, book the debate. Step
three, give fair moderation.
That's it.
Tens of thousands. >> I even had us in a single Rob.
>> I had Rob on a panel and I think I I think I corrected
him on something and then he had to debate me and I just like
I just rolled over and I took it. I was like, "My bad, my bad,
my bad." Mostly because
it's very intimidating debating
But um
yeah, anyway, go ahead, play the video.
>> So, step three, give fair moderation. That's it. Tens
of thousands in a single month. Apparently, Sarah's made tens
of thousands of dollars in a single month just from having these
debates on. Just shut up. Let me tell you what you don't do.
What you don't do is go in enemy territory and assist them with
running down one of my best friends and trolling him cuz you
think it's funsies.
Go [__] yourself.
Literally go [__] yourself. Unbelievable. These people
are
Ever seen me in a counter stream running down Sarah? I always
build her up.
I always build her up. I built these people up.
They just can't help it. I don't know what happens in these women's
brain. You get about a year. You get about a year out of any
woman who ever does any work with you. One year. And then that
knife comes in every single time. One year max. Never seen one
get past that threshold. Every
>> I'm in so much danger right now. >> single time.
There's >> so so many comments I could make. And by the
way, not Yes, I I could make a comment about Cherry. That would
be dangerous. But there's comments about so many other people
that I could make. Okay, Trio Logic. I could easily make comments,
right? I could easily like make a joke there. We've known each
other about a year. Listen, I I'd be in trouble from every angle.
All right. >> Didn't you raise money for this dude's missing
tooth? Yes, I know. Bad Andrew.
>> Radical coders. Radical coder came onto his stream and
he was like missing a tooth and Andrew's like, "Don't worry,
buddy. We'll pay for that." And then they donated to him. >> I
thought he might have also helped with Wix's tooth. Why are all
these people raising money for their missing teeth,
>> but I I guess Ryan got it handled right away. That's
cool. Uh, Val Valiv says, "Cherry has six months left. I think
we're going on just about two years of streaming together. You're
in 10
>> What do you mean six months? >> I don't know what
he's saying, but
>> we're getting married. He's going to spend the rest
of his life with me.
>> He's going to get me Canadian
>> I can still talk. Where'd you go? >> I just It
doesn't quite work as well when we don't use Discord as the actual
>> We're When we're in the same room. Yeah. doesn't work
at all. I'm like staring at him and he really thinks he did something
there and I can just still see
>> Uh,
good times. Good times. Good times. >> Bad smokeoky man.
>> Do that twice.
>> Okay. All right. I So, we went through that. I just
wanted to watch that rant of what Andrew said the steps were
to make sure you were successful being a part of his community
or whatever. There's a guy trolling Rob. There's another guy.
Oh, same guy trolling Rob here. So, if I go to part one, did
I have part one open here? No, that's speak easy.
Give me a second.
I'll open up part one here. And I I just want to see if I could
scroll through and see the counterpoints guy. Just Just be very
interesting if we had that here somewhere. Oh, we don't Do we
not get him? Oh, come on, man.
Is it not here somewhere? Oh, who's this? Another goofy troll.
Another goofy troll.
Nothing but goofy trolls. Okay. He doesn't watch the uh the counterpoints
guy. Come on. That's too bad. >> That would have been funny.
I would have liked to see Andrew Wilson's reaction to that guy.
That's too bad.
Okay, we'll uh
we will go and we will check out the the Rob video now. I think
we're ready to go to the Rob video. See here. Oh, this is from
tonight. All right. We'll go through some of the stuff from tonight.
>> Wait, don't we have to watch the Rob video first
to understand his energy >> Yeah, we will. We will.
>> we are. Yeah, sorry. I was just looking at what my other
what my other stream was here.
we are going like this. Let's open up. Thank you. Let me pull
the Rob video >> Yes, we did see about Sam Pepper. >> Rob
Rob. Yes, it used to be in the title, but we I don't know if
we'll get to it. I think we will. We still have a lot of time.
Four hours on the stream. Yes. Sam Pepper using young Indian
children for target practice, maming them for sport.
>> Oh, only four hours. >> It's real. It's true.
It's real. It's >> Uh, subscribe, donate,
uh, send kicks,
sign up to the Patreon. The sooner you guys donate, the sooner
he will drink caffeine and continue to stream later. >> Oh,
wow. >> Don't wait till the end.
>> Okay. We're trying to go all night >> apparently.
Sarah Tomato owes me $10,000 is what Rob's stream is called.
Okay. Or sorry, this is what his video is called. This is an
edited video, actually. >> I think I think
I think he doesn't know the power of the panel verse. >> Oh,
not the panel verse. Oh no, >> what the panelverse? Beware
the panel vers of the panel verse. I could just imagine Rob and
his editor. They're like two 40-year-old guys who are sitting
in a room. They're like, "Yeah, this Dragon Ball Z yet goes so
hard." It's not that it doesn't It's not that it's not funny.
>> No, it is so funny. Off voice over the >> It is
funny. Yeah. >> Who can know the great Sarah Tomato? The
power she wields. The power of the panel. I'll tell you exactly
what happened. Sarah and me have been a little chippy with each
other for a couple months, I guess, ever since I debated this
RTP guy. She wanted me to apologize because I brought up his
kids. I didn't bring up his kids in a
>> Oh [__] Rob Nor must have got a raid. Must
have got a raid from Andrew tonight. Thousand viewers whatsoever.
>> He was insulting me both before the stream and during
the stream. >> Although actually Rob could just get that
himself here if he's talking about any of this drama.
>> Um, he normally gets what does he normally get? 300
400. You in 40, >> Rob. Rob gets viewers. >> I just
I think a thousand is pretty high. This drama is suiting him
just
>> Frank, thank you very much for the gifted sub to one
toe over. Appreciate it, buddy. >> About how I clearly
couldn't get a woman and wouldn't be married and implying that
like I'm unattractive or something like that. I asked if he was
married. He said he used to be, but he big manned me that he
sleeps with a bunch of women. So, I said, "Do you have kids?"
Now, I asked that reason question for a reason. Not to insult
his kids. My gosh. parents have thought because
as ridiculous as it is, I never thought it was a big man. Oh
man, you sleep with a bunch of chicks. Cool.
But it goes from being like whatever. This is stupid, too. Yeah.
It's actually really tragic. If you have a family,
that's bad. That's really bad. That's it. That's all I said.
You have kids, then I wouldn't be bragging about
women. Why don't you settle down and find him a mother? Then
I said something. I don't even know if people could hear it,
but he claimed that he was gonna me and I was like, "You talk
like that in front of your kids or something like that." >> That
is weird. >> That was a weird comment. That was a weird
comment. >> That's it. This is after he was going after
me for my wife and [__] but I didn't care. I didn't
really I wasn't walking away there like I was just like, "You
gave me I gave you no problem." By the way, that's a theme that
you'll see. I think Sarah misinterprets with me. Nonetheless,
Sarah asked me for said I should apologize to him afterwards.
I >> Rob is married. Yeah, Rob is married. Rob's got uh
at least one kid, maybe multiple kids. >> At least one
kid. He's going to talk.
>> Something happened like RTP probably said, "I don't
want to come back." Uh because things got personal and then she
asked me to apologize. I said no. I never told people that Sarah
asked me to apologize. What I did was said that people suggested
that I apologize and I was wondering to my audience did they
think I went over the line and most of my audience said no but
a couple said yeah you still shouldn't have said kids I was like
well I'm not going to apologize and I told Sarah that and I was
like no hard feel >> there's like one of the there's there's
something going on where people
it's like somebody will question a person's maturity or their
conduct on the internet given they are a father and then everybody
who's too much of a coward to acknowledge that they're acting
like a loser on the internet goes, "Are you talking [__]
about my kids?" No, I'm mocking your inability to be a mature
and responsible parent for your kids. I'm not mocking your kids.
Why would I talk about your kids? I'm sure they don't control
the fact that they've got a loser for a parent, right? I I feel
like anybody who doesn't understand that that distinction is
a fine feelings. If you can't have me back on the show, no problem.
Totally get it. Not going to apologize. Um, apparently some people
made snide comments to snare about this. I came on the next day
and told my audience, "Don't [__] with Sarah. It's
not She didn't do any." That's fine. Ever since then, it's like
things have been chippy now. She has, you know, my audience always
wants me to go on these panels. Okay, I'm going to go on the
panel. Connor's there. Connor's talking about
real
after Charlie Kirk and on Charlie Kirk and stuff and everyone's
like, "Go get that. Go in the open panel and get that." So I
go on the open panel and I get that and he once he starts getting
blown out starts spuring out and just talking over me. It's constant
and then finally I start the moderator Sarah's just letting it
go. So I start talking over him and then Sarah will be like gentlemen
gentlemen both you stop it. And then he announces yeah Rob I
am going to interrupt you because I think you're wrong. So anytime
I think you say something that's wrong I'll interrupt. If I have
a point to make or if I feel like you're asking a question that
implies something, I'm going to interrupt you in order to point
it out. And if you're not in a you'll let me do >> Bragging
that he's going to interrupt. He proceeds to do it for the majority
of the debate. At one point in that debate, Sarah tells me
>> if if you disagree, like I don't know what the best
way to handle this in debates is, but it's like you're building
up, you know, multiple premises for your argument. I disagree
with one of your premises. We either need to talk about it now
or we need to pause and like we we probably need to talk about
it now because realistically if you finish all of the things
you're going to say if you take a fiveminute monologue and then
I have to respond to all of it. It's going to be difficult. I'm
probably just focusing on this one part. I'm probably even having
a hard time after I hear my disagreement I'm probably having
a hard time actually continuing to listen to you without focusing
on that and re like thinking about where my argument is there
that the reason he >> so like I understand the need to
feel like you should be interrupting you should be like saying
something. I understand that on counterpoints part I think he
was interrupting Rob a little bit you know not when required
but that's also part of debates. So >> at one point in
that debate Sarah tells me that the reason he's interrupting
me is because I said that he should stop. Dusty, why can't you
be quiet when other people are talking? >> Cuz he doesn't
like it when you tell him what to do. If you don't tell him what
to do, he'll actually oblige more
>> Okay. Um, yeah, I know that this guy like trying to
you. I I understand that you think he should just stop, but what
you need to do is not tell him not to [__] you. If
you don't tell him not to you, all right, then he will stop trying
to you, okay? Just just let it happen for a second and then he'll
stop when he realizes you don't like it. Okay? But let him realize
at his own pace. Okay? I let him talk unfettered basically. I
start talking, he interrupts. Sometimes he interrupts and then
he gets to speak after Sarah separates it. Sometimes he interrupts
and I get to speak. Sometimes he interrupts and then it's someone
else that gets to speak. But that's what happens. Now I wrote
it off. I b a little about the moderation, but I'm like fine.
But I wrote it. Okay. There's another thing that happens here
that is difficult to handle as a moderator as like a a moderator
anywhere.
Oh, hold on. Uh that's that when I think for all of these panels,
it's a lot easier for them to get liberals or centristish people
and it's a lot harder for them to get someone like Rob who will
fully own basically all of the populist positions, right? So
when you have Rob on a nine person panel, the odds are good that
like eight of those people want to talk to Rob, want to interrupt
Rob, want to disagree with Rob. So trying to balance talking
time in a way that's fair to them and to Rob is really difficult
because Rob's being talked to all the time and there will be
people disagreeing in different directions. It's really really
really really really hard to do like a a big chaos panel like
that with one person who sticks out like a sore thumb who's going
to get disagreed with by everybody there off in this sense. I
said he's the guest and I was the open panelist. Fine.
Next time I'm the guest. Sarah's friend Dusty,
who came on my show in the call-in portion and got wrecked for
lying about me. Dusty comes on the open panel. Same [__]
He's interrupting.
Like, what? What the? Now, I'm like, why does this make sense?
Now, here's the thing, right? Sometimes you have to know where
your bread is buttered. Do you think for a second Sarah would
have let someone talk over Andrew Wilson like that? You think
for a second when she knows the majority of the financial donations
I get are probably members of the crucible. You think for >> I
think I think this is probably true, right? Like Sarah would
definitely protect Andrew a lot more aggressively. Um not even
through like some principled failing on her part. It's like just
natural once somebody's responsible for trust me I get it. All
right. There's some natural inclination there. You're getting
tens of thousands of dollars. You're going to give this person
favorable treatment whether you mean to or not. Whether you're
like intentionally doing it, it'll just it'll hit out of nowhere.
Okay. Duh. It's a lot of money >> for a second. Of course
not. We all know >> not good. You should try to control
it. You should have a way of thinking about it and controlling
it. >> But she going to leave Connor talk over him like
that and brag about it. She going to leave Dusty talk over him
like that and brag about it. By the way, that's okay. And I'm
no Andrew Wilson. I'm not bringing her in the views and money
that Andrew Wilson is. And it's kind of a smart business move.
Don't don't sh you know, don't over the person that's helping
your channel out the most. I totally get it. I get that. And
I'm not Andrew. Perfectly fine. But at some point, and I mentioned
this this morning, I'm better than these stupid act losers. I
don't need them. I don't need to go on and talk to these no-name
losers that I've wrecked in debates over and over again. I don't
need it. And if the game's going to be, oh, we know, we'll just
keep interrupting Rob. And Sarah will just sit there and let
it go. And then when I'm like, what the is this? Are they going
to shut up or whatever, Sarah's going to be like, Rob, you asking
them to not interrupt why they're interrupting? I don't need
it. Now, am I wishing Sarah any ill? No. After it happens enough,
I'm like, you know what? Hey, my name's Rob Nor. Channel's normal
America. Thanks for having me. I'm out. Oh, the trolls. Rub rage
quit. Blah blah blah. I'm just it's not worth my time.
I could think of a thousand things that are more productive that
I could be doing or more
that letting some nobody
shout over me while I can't get a word in edgewise. That's it.
Done. Don't give a [__] In that same panel,
Dusty's buddy, Brick, I think was his name. I was like, uh, we're
going to back and forth. I'm like, can you answer this? He's
like, no, I refuse. I'm like, well, then [__] it.
Either he goes or I go because what's the [__] sense
of being here? If I'm the panelist and the people that are arguing
with me are like, "Nope, we refuse to engage." I don't do well
with ultimatums. I'm like, "If it came out that way, I didn't
mean it as an ultimatum. I meant why the [__] am
I here if they're going to be here? I have nothing to say." Have
you heard of this >> I don't believe you answer to to any
of your questions. >> All right. Hey, Sarah, I'm out then.
If the only two people here that are going to talk doesn't want
to respond to me, then I'm out. You get to hang out with those
two. So, it's me or them. I don't give a >> I'm sad. >> Well,
to be fair, Rob, uh I don't play >> Now, now, now, now,
did Rob actually accurately characterize this? Cuz this is my
big problem with Rob. He says, "Oh, I didn't mean for it to seem
like I was giving an ultimatum and then he gives a totally
unambiguous
ultimatum." Right.
Hold on. Let me pull it back. Let me pull it back and we'll listen
to him again. >> Listen to him explain. In that same panel,
Dusty's buddy, Brick, I think was his name. I was like, "Uh,
we're going to back and forth." I'm like, "Can you answer this?"
He's like, "No, I refuse." And I'm like, "Well, then [__]
it. Either he goes or I go because
what's the [__] sense of being here? If I'm the panelist
and the people that are arguing with me are like, "Nope, we refuse
to engage. I don't do well with ultimatums." I'm like, "If it
came out that way, I didn't mean it as an ultimatum. I meant
why the [__] am I here if they're going to be here?
I have nothing to say." Clay, have you heard of this story? >> I
don't believe you know that one. to to any of your questions.
>> All right. Hey Sarah, I'm out then. If the only two
people here that are going to talk doesn't want to respond to
me, then [__] it. I'm out. You get to hang out with
those two. So, it's me or them. I don't give a [__]
>> I'm sad. >> Well, like I get I get how he did
this, right? I get how I get how he did this. I get why he feels
frustrated, but he does actually give like an explicit ultimatum
here, which is just a bit odd to me, right? that he's going to
get he's going to be like, "Yeah, uh, listen, me or them." Oh,
I didn't mean for it to sound like an ultimatum. Now, I think
that's about as bad as Rob's conduct gets. So, this is what I
interpret as Sarah saying, you try to with the panel versus you
try to like control these chaos things. You try to say this is
how I need it and you don't understand that when you do that,
other people will with you, right? That's sort of Sarah's position
on all of this. So, I don't think she was quite as egotistical
as it seemed on the oh, you shouldn't [__] with the
panel verse comment, but
I she also didn't control the way she said that very well.
>> To be fair, Rob, uh I don't play that >> So, if
you hold on, I'm going to put it to you this way. I host open
panels for a reason. It is up to the chat to boot people from
the panel. >> Uh if you want to send a brigade to send
$100 to officially boot somebody from the go that way. if you
want me to like to do something then 100 bucks 100 bucks >> but
I don't play the whole well it's me or them kind of because that
kind of negates the entirety of >> I will say like in Rob's
defense if he's talking to somebody and one of the people participating
go no I'm not going to answer anything you say as your most popular
person trying to interact with one of your open guests where
the [__] does that open guest ego come from what
the [__] is the point why is she not going hey actually
participate or I'll kick you the [__] out loser the
do you think this is? Like if you're if you're moderating actively,
that's probably where that should go. Like, hey, literally the
person who's actually got a bigger bigger audience here is trying
to talk directly to you. Are you actually just going to go I
don't want to answer any of your questions? Well, leave. Let
someone else take your spot from you >> of my show. >> So
then, okay, that's fair. So then, uh, I will just sit here while
they say we're not going to respond to anything you say.
>> You don't have to. That's fine. I'm not going to like
I'm not going to force you
>> uh I don't think most of these I don't think all of
these guys or even most of them are conservative. Although these
guys might be this dude's not conservative. I would have guessed
that this guy's not conservative if Rob's trying to talk to him.
I don't know about the rest. >> Do anything you don't want
to do. Okay. I I don't care. Um but I don't play the like me
or them thing cuz then like that's kind of like an move. Number
one. >> Well, no no no. It's not an I'm not saying that
you have to boot them. I'm saying what's the point of this panel
if the only three people talking if they're like we're not going
to respond to anything you say. We're not going to we're not
going to answer questions. >> Then uh somebody else can
uh add ask questions too. That's fine. >> I left the panel.
I But uh that that was like an oh that was not a great response.
Listen, I'm here. I'm trying to interact. These people say they
won't talk to me. Nobody else is talking. What are we doing here?
And she's like well someone else could talk. I you got like a
bigger creator on. I'd probably
I would think it would be it would make the most sense to try
to get them interacting try to get your your people your participants
interacting too
for them to just go yeah we don't want to talk to Rob like well
what what is what is anyone doing there did a little griffin
by the way something Andrew taught me to do by the end of the
night try to get that super chat goal if you haven't I come back
and I'll admit I was like I think I moderation sucks I I think
I sucks what the [__] I'm just getting yelled over
whatever
anyways no hard feelings things and I don't give a, right? I
can't help that some people in my audience also thought that
the moderation sucked. So, apparently they said something to
Sarah. I'm guessing. I don't know. I don't watch her channel.
She sent me a message and Andrew read this on stream today cuz
he asked about it. She says, "There's a secret weapon to panels.
You can't show." This is the next day. By the way, this is Yeah,
this is Sarah's message to Rob. Rob having been in the space
a longer time. Rob having run panels. Rob having the experience.
Rob being the bigger channel
that I could see how the
the sort of tone of this might be very frustrating for Rob. She
says there's a secret weapon to panels. You can't show This is
the next day. There's a secret weapon to panels. You can't show
any of your cards at all. By that I mean if someone's annoying
you, interrupting or poking at things that raise your temperature,
you can't let it bother you visually.
The other panelists subconsciously will see those trigger points
and zero in on it. They do it every time to you. You're an easy
target. It's unsolicited advice. I'm aware.
But the best tip I could give you is to stop reacting to their
pokes and prods. Open panels are meant to be fun, light-hearted,
and relaxed. They have to be that way or else they wouldn't be
so fun and inviting to anyone. Witty banter plus topic discussion
equals a great panel. You often enter them very harshly and seriously
and demanding. I've noticed you take insults very personally
and that's what they'll run you out and that's why they'll run
you out every time because it's a killjoy to everyone else.
Why is this guy taking things so serious? You going to laugh
at the digs, talk through the interruptions
and roll with the punches. Everyone throws their punches,
takes the hits, laughs, and comes back the next day at the clean
slate ready for more trash. Talking about an open panel being
too chaotic is like complaining that the sky is blue. They will
always be chaotic. You can either handle them or you can't.
Now, when I received that message on October 8th, I was [__]
livid. I was like, >> So, yeah, it's like it's sort of
talking down to Rob. I know some people this could seem like
maybe she thinks that she's just being kind, right? That that
message to somebody else could be good.
I I don't know. It It's sort of
maybe if you're Rob, you could argue it betrays like a lack of
respect already,
>> Light-hearted and relaxed. They have to be that way
or else they wouldn't be so fun and inviting to anyone. Witty
banter plus topic discussion equals a great panel. You often
enter them very harshly and seriously and demanding. I've noticed
you take insults very personally, and that's what they'll run
you out, and that's why they'll run you out every time because
it's a >> It is kind of correcting his behavior. It's uh
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Hey, you're getting shoved in the wrong pigeon
hole here, is Rob Noah, right? And nobody likes that. Nobody
likes getting put in the wrong box. Oh, you're really bad at
taking insults, Rob. And because you're so bad at taking insults,
I don't know if panels are quite right for you. And Rob's sitting
there like, just let me talk and I'll take any insult thrown
at me. Just let me talk. Joy to everyone else.
Why is this guy taking things so serious? You got to laugh at
the digs. Talk through the interruptions
and roll with the punches. Everyone throws their punches,
takes the hits, laughs, and comes back the next day at the clean
slate, ready for more. Trash talking about an open panel being
too chaotic is like complaining that the sky is blue. They will
always be chaotic. You can either handle them or you can't.
Now, when I received that message on October 8th, I was [__]
livid. I was like, you [__]
Who the [__] are you? You want to know what I thought?
>> Hey, Rob, I got some advice for you, okay? Have you
thought about not being such a sensitive
Rob? Rob >> I when Sarah sent that message, you want to
know what I wanted to say out loud? I wanted to say what the
are you? What do you do? Moderate poorly? You're one of the dime
a dozen people that bring on panelists that let them be the entertainment
because you're incapable of doing it yourself. >> These
comments don't feel anywhere near as bad when I stream solo like
95% of the time. Okay, these these comments used to sting and
now I stream solo like 95 99% of the time and now they're just
like, "Yeah, those panelists who just bring other people on to
be the entertain those people." By the way, there's nothing wrong
with that. But don't get it twisted. I need your advice. Who
the [__] are you? That's what I wanted to say. But
I have a tremendous wife and I was like, "Can you believe this?"
My wife said, "Rob, take a breath. Don't respond for 24 hours.
Then you say what you want." >> Okay, but that's not a
panel. All right, that's not a panel, >> but you should
probably wait 24 hours. And I did. And I'm glad I did because
I didn't respond to her. Instead, I came on my channel because
every night that there's an open panel on Sarah's channel or
anywhere else,
my audience is like, "Go on the open panel. Go on the open panel.
Go on the open panel." So, I had to explain to my audience why
I would no longer do that. And you go back and you can watch
what I said. I said, "Listen, I've been frustrated about the
moderation on Sarah's channel and other open panels." cuz I wasn't
trying to make it just about and I was like, but I was messaged
by someone that informed me that I'm looking at the open panels
all wrong. It's not supposed to be a serious debate. It's supposed
to be like a show, like a Jerry Springer show. And that's fine.
If that's what people like, fine. But it's not for me. That's
it. I said, "So, I'll continue to do a debate that Sarah moderates,
but I won't do the open panel." Done. Now, to the rest of what
she said about I take insults very seriously. Why? Because I
give it back. Cuz if someone says like, "You're a fat fuck."
And I'm like, "Dude, you look like dudes bend you over." It's
like, "Well, you're taking that seriously. What are you talking
about?" The only thing that it looks like I take seriously cuz
it's true. Is when stupid >> Was that his response? You're
gay. I'm fat. Yeah. Well, you're gay. You look >> Stupid
[__] keep talking over me over and over. The insults.
I don't give a [__] I I just don't give a [__]
You call me a fat this that don't don't bother me at all. So,
I don't know where she gets this. We are an easy target. Fan
of the show named Toasted reached out to me and was like, "Uh,
hey, I'd like to set up this debate." Now, listen, I want to
say this, and I have nothing against this guy, Toasted. But I
have to say this. I sort of just half paid attention
if I'm honest. And I I don't mean that in a negative way. I mean,
I get a bunch of people that are like, "Will you do the show
for me? Will you do this show with me?" And almost always, I
say, "Yes, sure." Just this week I did two podcasts
of streamers that aren't big streamers that have like
minute you had to have your wife [__] wrangle is
very unbecoming.
Uh I mean is it [__] wrangling if he just wants to
go like you?
I don't know. He's like oh it doesn't sound it doesn't sound
like his response was really different. It sounds like he was
still felt the same way anyway. His wife is just like hey maybe
don't respond now.
Or or maybe you see it that way. I don't know. 40 people watching.
Monday I did an excellent podcast. You should check it out. It's
called Bruise and Cruise. Real awesome guy. We just talked about
life and wasn't a debate. Great time. >> The guy averages
60 views per video. He doesn't do live streams. I don't give
a It's fun. So when people that are like, "Hey, I recognize their
name." Like, "Hey, would you like to go on a show? Would you
like to debate?" I'll say, "Sure." This guy because of the drama
with this guy Dusty that I'd had recently was like, "You want
to debate Dusty and Radical Coder?" I said, "Sure." You debate
with this trippy guy? Sure. Uh, who should mod blah blah blah?
Sarah is like, I don't want Sarah to mod. Is there a problem
with you and Sarah? I was like, no, I don't want to talk about
it. All right. >> So, that's that's the interesting thing
is I feel like Rob did have a problem with Sarah. Obviously,
from the time of that DM, didn't want Sarah moderating basically
was kind of like annoyed with Sarah. I think this second part
where Sarah goes and is a part of that thing.
I think there was already some tension there already problems
and then it it kind of spilled over and the fact that they didn't
solve it, they didn't squash it before it spilled over into the
public and then Sarah was on a stream where they were Rob and
trying to troll him. I think that's what made Andrew Wilson cut
ties. I think there was a lot more going on here than they're
they're like acknowledging it, but I think Rob might have I wonder
if Rob didn't say something before this to anyone involved with
the Crucible. And I wonder if like they hadn't had some kind
of conversation before this at all cuz it's kind of funny that
as he's pointing out, he said, "No, I don't want I don't want
Sarah for his debate." That was uh what, three days ago? Three
or four days ago. >> All right. I sort of got lost in the
shuffle and I saw that he kept messaging me and I just basically
ain't saying anything and he's like it's going to be blood sports
and you know I told people that like the topic's going to be
the insurrection act but it could go anywhere. You could get
into real personal okay that's fine but I thought it was going
to be a debate. That's what I thought. So we get there we do
the debate and opening statements were fine except totally no
one's fault. Um by the way Trippy I saw Andrew say Trippy was
the moderator. Trippy was not. He was the host but debater. Nova
was the moderator. But the host is what's going to matter when
it came to who to to kick me or not. That's wasn't on the moderator.
I was on the host. So I get over there. The debate starts off.
Opening statement's great. We start arguing.
They put me in a one-on-one with Dusty. It's fine. Dusty gets
blown the [__] out. He knows it. I know it. Everyone
watching knows it. So we get out of the one-on-one and Coders
starts blah blah blah blah. Okay. And he's just, in fact, I don't
even have to tell you. I could just show you. Make up your own
mind. Now, the context is when I talk to people like Coder and
Dusty, this is what it's always like. Constant interruptions,
this that the other bull, whatever. So, at this point right here,
as I'm talking to Dusty, I'm actually enjoying myself thoroughly.
I think it's a good debate. Pretty reasonable. >> Your
number. No, the other thing to say and this is no one's fault
of anyone involved, but the last debate like the last five debates
I've had like this. I debated Destiny on Tom Fuller's show a
couple months ago. Same constant berging out interrupting. It's
just getting old. That's all. At least Destiny's a big name though.
Who the are these people? >> I I don't I disagree that.
You see, explain and you tell me if you agree or not. Because
when we >> uh I just think about that one Tik Tok dude
who was debating against uh not so Erdite and totally like stalked
her down and made her look so ridiculous by just being calm,
having like a deep voice and continued to like re hit on his
uh his same criticisms and same questions over and over again,
pointing out her contradictions. I think that was like one of
the most effective anti-spur debate styles I've ever seen. I
forget the guy's name. He's a really popular Tik Tok >> dude.
Redo. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Really po. >> How did
she do that? >> I have no idea. Yeah. I think he was a
long-haired guy, black guy. Just like consistently reiterated
his debates over and over. Call of Duty lobby style of being
school of being calm and winning. Well, I feel like you're saying
that because of his race, evil Johnny Braavos. It makes me feel
a little awkward to agree with you, but a little bit. Yeah, >> it's
a one-on-one. You can see so no one else can interrupt. They're
not there. Great. Fine. No problem here. Allow people to change
people. >> Um, correct. Close this door. >> So, so
now we open it up. Okay. No problem. Now, Trippy is supposed
to be my partner, even though he's the host of the debate. And
Nova, who I don't know, by the way, I have no hard feelings against
Trippy or Nova, which I'll get to in a minute here.
>> Did Andrew popularize smoking your basement and debate
people? Is someone else doing that? >> Also, do we know
who this powdered dusty person is? Why? >> No, I don't
know. I don't know about him. Yeah, I got no idea.
is somebody else smoking and debating? I think a lot of people
vape, but I've not seen a lot of
dude in the middle of >> Then I'll finish with this. So
then your argument that we can't enforce immigration laws that
are on the book because people will act in violence is giving
in to political terrorism. If you have states and communities
that have massive illegal immigrant populations because we have
not been enforc because the government's been lack lax on enforcing
those laws and you go in one day against the the local community's
>> Yes, that's promise I'll get to.
And by the way, there is also a lot of controversy about whether
or not they are actually just enforcing the law because courts
keep ruling against the way they're carrying out their jobs.
And the so far the debate's going pretty good and then you'll
see Show me one >> Show me one time it's Show me one time
it's made it to the Supreme Court and they've upheld those court
decisions.
>> I mean these are still a lot of things are pending because
it's happening in real time, >> right? And time what we
have is what we and what we have in real time is ICE is carrying
out what they're trying to do. They are arresting people. They
are successfully doing it. The DHS is bragging about it. They
are successfully doing their job and police are arresting people.
They're charging people. The courts are ruling. the every the
system is working as it should and you're demanding that we invoke
the insurrection act despite all that. >> Okay. Well, one
one what we see in real time is the courts are being activist
and ruling decisions that they absolutely 100% know. >> It's
rulings you disagree with. You're alleging they're activists
because you don't like the rulings. You don't like the rulings.
You So you call an >> I understand that I understand the
need to spur outright. We've been talking for the past like 10
minutes. I haven't even got to be up here. >> So what?
When you get a one-on-one, you'll get to talk for 10 minutes
and I won't have the opportunity to interrupt you. You made a
point. I'm responding. >> She doesn't even know what the
Insurrection Act is. >> You made a point and now you're
spuring out. That's what you're doing. I'm the only person who's
read from the insurrection act here.
>> I spent the past three days reading. >> We read
it this morning on stream
for the first time. I've been >> this morning.
>> I Yeah, I thought that was hilarious,
>> Oh. Um, >> was this morning the first time you
talked about it? I I read about the insurrection act this morning.
>> I've been studying. >> You're the one that made
the claim that the only time the feds can enforce the laws through
positive
said the military. I said the military. >> [__]
rude. Anyways, the point that I'm trying to >> What do
you mean? Wait, wait, wait. Do you deny that that even if I even
though I said the feds, you acknowledged as soon as the debate
started, I clarified even if I had misspoken earlier, right?
You acknowledge that? >> I think he he does not acknowledge
>> I don't think that I misspoke, by the way. I'm pretty
sure I said the military. I think you actually misheard, but
that's fine. >> Okay. We can see that these are activist
courts and there is no understanding of the law whatsoever. That
>> this is an assertion. You have no you have no evidence
that they're activist courts. You just disagree with the rulings.
You're such a baby.
>> Now that's it. It's evident to me. There's no moderation
going on. It's the same song and dance. Now, is this the >> Well,
you'd have to hear the whole argument, right? Pooped my pants
off. You'd have to hear the whole argument to know whether or
not Coder won the argument. I think he's making a good point.
Like what do you mean by activist judges? Right? Like you have
to you actually have to say what what evidence you have that
there's activist judges doing these things instead of just saying
it's not what I want to have >> I'm just laughing at the
dusty dude having read >> the insurrection act this morning.
>> This morning? >> Yeah. The worst I've ever been
interrupted. No, I don't need these people. I did this debate
as a as a favor to a dude that likes me in chat that set the
debate up. I don't need these people. I don't need them. And
I'm not. Here we go again. Same. I'm just gonna get spurred out
on interrupted the whole debate again. Now, I have said on my
channel for quite some time, I'm a pretty good debater. I have
no clue. I have no clue what the strategy is at this point. I
don't know. I've tried damn near everything. I've asked the moderator.
When I ask the moderator, people like Sarah tell me it's my problem
that I'm appealing to the moderator. That's putting a target
on my back. People say that's a move. I've said, "Hey, you peace
out. I'm leaving. That's a move. That's rage quitting. I've suggested
people putting timers on. People like, "Oh, appeal to the moderator.
What a bitch." I've shouted over them. Wow, Rob, you look like
an unhinged. I thought you were supposed to be a good debater.
These
people can't debate. They know that if they have a civil radical
coder, one time I was on a panel with him.
Again, I I do agree with Rob that he can get like dogpiled sometimes.
I would agree with that. I agree that he
probably he's pretty good just in terms of picking up people's
uh what would you call like their contradictions. If they have
any internal contradictions, he's pretty good at picking them
up. He's pretty good at identifying them in the moment. I will
say the thing he complains about the most is getting interrupted.
And he is perfectly comfortable interrupting himself. And I've
had this issue with him when he's been on my stream.
But I the issue another issue I'm seeing here is I just don't
get enough context to see how much he's being interrupted to
see if it's worth him complaining about. So I we'd have to go
back.
Uh I I feel like that clip was not that bad, but we'll see. And
I was talking about the double standard between how the law was
enforced between the Trump the Trump team versus the Hillary
team >> and the Biden team. And I came up with 20 like
I don't know an hour a half hour before the show. I came up with
a list of 20 examples off the top of my head. He claimed I was
spreading disinformation. So, here was the deal I gave him. Now,
this is the worst of advice I could ever give someone. I gave
him the entirety of my notes. I said, "Here you go." And I gave
him a month to prepare. One month without changing the notes,
I said, "There you go, buddy. You prepare. You have one month."
You guys think this actually happened? That's like pretty rough.
If somebody says, "You're lying. You're doing disinformation."
You say, "Here's all the points I've made. Here's like all of
my research. Go ahead, prove me wrong. We'll debate again in
a month." And you got nothing. You get like blown. That would
be rough, man.
But I don't know. I You'd have to go track this down. I wonder
where this is. Maybe this would be content at some >> And
I want you to go through these notes without my ability to change
it >> and I want you to show me where the disinformation
is. And he got absolutely
wrecked. He got wrecked. He had a month with my exact notes.
That was the topic. You think I'm afraid to debate that guy?
He knows. He knows what would happen. So he adapts the tactic
the same thing when I debated Destiny last time. I'm just going
to shout over you the whole time and now. Ah, no, you're wrong.
Or when I debate Connor, same same every time.
Now, it's one thing if I get an invite for here's the deal, right?
There's a lot of reasons to take debates and the last debate
course I did for the curse, I talked about this was the lesson
I did. It sounds so dumb. The precursor to knowing, right,
>> dude. This is for debate you guys. He's talking about
his This is You don't have to pay $500 to to learn this stuff,
okay? He's given it to you for free.
>> What to do in a debate, like how to be a good debater
is asking yourself, why am I debating? Now, that sounds dumb.
And I almost felt sheepish like the debate course people or,
you know, the debate club people are probably like, "What? This
is dumb." But it's actually one of the most important pieces
of advice I can give someone.
>> Let's say that you're debating because >> why
are you debating? Okay, we got 32 minutes left on this. I need
to >> use the bathroom one more time cuz I should drank
a caffeine over the past like hour and a half. I'll be right
back. I'm also going to get water cuz I didn't get any I didn't
get any water the last time I was up. I'll be right back and
we're going to continue on. I'm looking around. We've got the
Sam
Pepper stuff. Him maming Indian children for sport. What else
do we have tonight? We've got Oh, the entire uh blonde politics.
Blonde politics, right? Whatever the silly serious's name is
right now. We've got her whole video on on MAGA Magic. Really
good video. Uh I'm I'm very interested in that. We can check
that out as well. I think that video might go for a while cuz
I do want to see I want to see if timelines are all correct there.
But I'm I don't know. I watched it earlier today. It was very
good. So, >> Is Darius in jail? Darius was literally on
streams yesterday. He's absolutely not in jail. One took over.
you want your channel to grow and make money.
Okay, let's say you're debating because you want to come across
as a real likable guy. Let's say you're debating because it's
just a hobby and you want to learn. Or maybe you're debating
because you're trying to convince an audience to vote for a particular
candidate. I give one example that you guys might know from Andrew.
Andrew debated this Mormon guy. He was a very pleasant man. Andrew
crushed him. It objectively crushed this dude and the dude knew
it. He knew that on the individual facts he was getting the beat
out of him. Andrew's goal was to prove in a polite way because
he's not trying to sh on people of the Mormon faith, but that
they're going the wrong way. This guy's goal was to make Mormons
seem real nice.
You know what's funny? They both achieved their goal. The guy
that Andrew debated got [__] wrecked, but he was
a humble loser. He was And so when he walks away, it's like,
"Yeah, I lost the argument, but was that ever my goal?" He's
like, "Well, I It's just faith. It's just faith. And it's been
real nice talking to you. You guys should come on over." Now,
there may have been 10, 20 people that were like, "I'll check
this guy out." Why do I debate?
Well, before this was my job,
like streaming full-time, I debated because I used to debate
in college and I loved it. It was a game and I wanted to play
a game much like maybe you would play Call of Duty cuz it's fun.
That's why that's why I'm debating. Now, there are certain debates
that I have different rationale. Four months before the election,
I went into I will not talk [__] on Trump no matter
what. All day, every day, and everything I did when it came to
politics, get Trump elected, get Trump elected, get Trump elected.
After that, here's where Trump [__] up. He screwed
up here. He screwed up there. But not those four months. Every
debate I took. And you can see my debate strategy was marketkedly
different. you might debate some I might to take a debate with
someone. >> Sucks so badly when you're like
Bob's like obviously like a good person on an interpersonal level
and he's just like I had four months where I absolutely did everything
in my ability everything in my power to get Trump elected. It's
like really man really.
>> Well, that's like that's the thing that everybody teaches
you or tried to stress out like
is everyone who's a Trump supporter like a bad person. Like I
have family that are a Trump supporter, MAGA supporters.
you try to villainize all of them and you will lose more people
than you gain. >> Yeah, sure. I'm just saying I >> But
you have that instinct right there. You have that instinct in
you. No. Well, sorry. I'm saying that if you're supporting Trump,
like at this point, I feel like
I could I could almost even forgive like >> this point.
I wouldn't say >> there's also there's just a huge difference
between people being able to establish like what's going to happen,
like understanding consequences or or having like valid opinions
or reads on what's going to happen given their vote versus how
they are on an interpersonal level. So, yeah, I would obviously
say there are really good people who
who would vote Trump. There's almost certainly but but the idea
that somebody who's like a major online political commentator
doesn't understand sort of the downstream effects of the vote
is weirder to me. That's like a more aberant thing that Rob could
be a really good person and still want some of those downstream
effects that are obviously in my opinion like morally bankrupt.
I don't know. Anyway,
that's that's all someone cuz there's a lot of people watching.
That's good. I might debate someone that I don't want to debate
on a show like Tim Pull Show or Piers Morgan because there's
a big audience,
right? There's no shame in that. Fine. I might debate someone
because I think they're a challenge. Why the would I debate these
jokers? They bringing in an audience? No. They a challenge? No.
So, why am I doing it? Well, because I have fun debating. And
it doesn't have to be a big audience for me to have fun. But
you know when I stop having fun? when people won't stop interrupting.
Now, my entire reason for being here is gone.
I don't give a anymore. If you can't shut your [__]
mouth for 3 seconds to listen to me respond, then you >> I
don't need this. It'd be different if it was bigger named people
or if it was people that I thought were more competent debaters
or it was on a bigger platform like Piers Morgan, I'd probably
stick it out. But over and over, I've been asked myself and I've
asked my audience. I'm like, "What am I supposed to do? This
keeps happening." Sarah said it. You saw in that DM said, "You're
a target now. They do this stuff because they know it bothers
you." Bothers me. The people interrupting me, so I can't get
a word out. Yeah, I guess that's a little bothersome. Sure. I
noticed Sarah wouldn't allow someone like Andrew to be bothered
that way cuz Andrew would say, "Um, what the is this? If you're
not going to let me talk, I'm out of here. Goodbye." So, it's
at this moment after Ryan is showing that he's going to interrupt.
And I'm like, "Here we go again." We're 20 minutes into a two-hour
debate that it's going to be me the entire debate going, "Let
me finish."
And then they all get Rob's getting more upset with it. I'm done.
So, I say this. I'm going to refuse to speak while people interrupt
me. I don't give a [__] I'll sit here silently. >> That's
fine. Awesome. Then I That means I get to talk more, right? Okay.
>> So, I say then I'm going to refuse to speak if people
are interrupting me. I'll sit here silently. My opponent says,
"Cool. That's more time for me to talk." All right. Now, I'm
thinking right now, what am I gonna do here? What's the plan?
>> See, this is again just optical. Uh, like I don't think
this looks good
for Rob. I think what Rob needs to do is decide whether or not
he can get invested in like these tier panels. Cuz if you can't
get invested the same way you would, if you can't debate like
you would against, let's say you were debating Destiny, you'd
never roll over and show your belly like that for Destiny. He
would never ever do that. Desi's interrupting him. He will always
keep fighting, right? And I think you just shouldn't show up
on any panel where you're not willing to do that. Like that.
That's got to be a shift for you cuz if you're just going to
go, "Okay, well, I'm not going to be Blood Sports Rob. I'm just
going to leave. I'm not going to talk cuz you won't let me talk."
That I I feel like that doesn't fit your vibe. It doesn't fit
the character that you've built up on the internet where you're
like this big badass debater who can't be talked over, who can
take a breath and speak for like 10 minutes straight. I feel
like you're just eating up that caricature that you've built
of yourself.
>> So I this this feels like the caricature for me. >> Which
one? >> Not I don't think it's a character. This it feels
consistent to me, but mostly because I've seen him in the panel
space for years. >> Oh, you feel like him complaining about
this getting interrupted and stuff? >> Uh like making sure
that the moderation is fair
and
yeah, being able to press somebody to to have like the debate.
I agree with you.
I think I think right here is you leave. I I think the the thing
where he's like, I'm not going to talk because you guys won't
let me talk. I didn't think that was the move. I don't think
it looks good, but >> Well, I would say does it not look
like he's winning now? >> You're not talking into your
mic, >> Sorry. Sorry. Does it not look like he's winning
now?
I feel like not dropping it. I feel like being aggressive about
>> He's winning it now cuz Andrew Wilson came in and like
nuked an entire country for him, right? He's like he's like a
little country. >> But that's what you're supposed to do
when you have allies
and you've got like the smaller countries. They're going to what?
Tie their ropes together and some terrorism. Build a coalition
to take you down. They feel like you're the the mediumsized crab
that they can coal >> whatever come together and take down.
>> No,
yours. >> Sure. I I agree with you that like you could
do that. You could say it's tactically like valid to do. And
if there's anybody that's in this space that has the time and
the energy and when even when this did not have the time, he
was always always on Twitter on panels
endlessly like the Energizer Bunny going from the top of every
debate. He will never drop anything this He's still going to
talk about Hunter Biden's laptop like next month >> again.
It is exactly who I think like he would be. I feel like him and
Pisco did was it both of them or was it just Pisco? I just feel
like once in a while you'd see one of them talk about it for
a second on a panel and then out of nowhere like the Kool-Aid
man the other one would just enter out of nowhere be like you
just said did you just say Jamal Bowman didn't do the didn't
do an insurrection it's like oh god not again not again >> that
message from Sarah is so funny because she is the person who
needed a DM to be told who Rob was
>> I honestly the first time I heard that DM get read I
didn't sound as bad and then I listened a second time or closely
I'm like oh No, that is like >> that is like really condescending.
>> you don't know the penal space. You started a fight
with a guy you can never end. Pisco is still fighting him from
5 years ago. >> Good luck. >> And Rob and I don't
know right now. >> So again, the system is working. Police
are arresting people. Even the ones who assault officers, they're
being arrested. People are being charged. People are committing
crimes are being arrested. The system is working as it's supposed
to. The insurrection act is And now I know what I'm going to
do. That's how long it took me to be like, you know what would
be funny this time? I'm just going to mute these [__]
and mute myself. If they if Ryan says cool, you sit there silent
because I got [__] to say, then talk all you want,
[__] You can have the whole show, big man. You can
have it all. That's how quick I came up with. I know what I'll
do. I'm not just going to leave the panel. They'll say you rage
quit. So, I'll keep my picture there and I'll talk to my audience.
Everybody's a winner. Ryan can say that I out. He gets all the
time to talk. He's the greatest debater in the world. He had
so much important [__] to say. There you go. You
get all the time in the world. I remind you what did >> Rob's
such a dick sometime. >> He say I'm going to refuse to
speak while people interrupt. >> Oh yeah. Yeah. You know
what you want? You want more time to talk? Go ahead. Everybody
wants to hear you talk. Go >> Me. I don't give a I'll sit
here silent. That's fine. Awesome. Then I that means I get to
talk. >> I'll sit here silent. Cool. That's fine. Awesome.
You got it, bud. How'd their panel go once I left? And Andrew's
absolutely right. And it's something I didn't say this morning.
They don't have a show without me. I am the audience there. I'm
a small fish, but I'm a bigger fish than them. If I get like
Sam Cedar to come on and debate me tomorrow. You think I'm just
going to spur out and interrupt him the whole time? So, he's
like, "You know what, man? I don't need this. I got a way bigger
audience than you. Go [__] yourself." That would
be real dumb of me. So, that's it. That's what happened in a
vacuum. If you just look at that and say, "That's not the worst
interruption I've ever seen." Totally true. Other fair criticisms.
You could have handled it better. You could have done something
else. I think probably if I'm Rob, especially given Rob's reputation,
I I'm gonna probably I'm going to maintain this. I understand
why he wants difference. I understand why he feels like that's
not worth his time. I think he probably needs to do a better
job of turning down opportunities where he's not willing to get
in the mud with people to some extent. Like to some extent at
all, right? Like because that didn't seem like a massive interruption
and he just didn't have the it it just sucks for me to see like
I'm bigger than you. This isn't worth my time. you. Even if that's
true,
I don't like I personally feel like it's weird to say that or
it's weird to um Yeah, it's just weird to say that to people
like you just shouldn't be there if they're not worth your time,
I think. >> Well, I don't know if he's saying that to the
panelists cuz he made the point that like, hey, I go on these
smaller podcasts. I talk to people with like seven viewers. I'm
not an ego person, >> but the panel host is the one who's
treating me like like they can just walk all over me. I think
he knew this was a newer panel host as well. This is somebody
who like doesn't regularly host panels or something. >> Well,
she doesn't act like it. >> She doesn't act like it. >> the
Nova person. >> Oh, Nova. Nova. >> Yeah, the Nova
person. The one who's in like if we go back. >> Oh, okay.
I didn't >> person Nova Star is moderating this one. And
I I don't think they've moderated it before or they they apparently
haven't moderated very often before. And so Rob is getting mad
about how people are talking over him >> and mad that like
these people are being rude to him. And I'm just like, well,
yeah, that will happen if you just go talk to nobody's. I think
probably you just don't waste your time talking to
is probably where you go. That's what happened in a vacuum. If
you just look at that and say that's not the worst interruption
I've ever seen. Totally true. Other fair criticisms. You could
have handled it better. You could have did something else. It's
true. I could have I I don't Some people might be disappointed
that I was like you. My point was you asked me to be silent because
you wanted to keep interrupting because you had so much to say.
Okie dokie. I'll be silent now. Let's see how well your time
goes. Let's see how much fun you have and let's see how many
views you get. Good luck. Jake rattlesnake raids me. So, I'm
feeling a little mischievous cuz I like with Jake. Jake, what'd
you think of the next move here? What' you think of what I did
Oh well maybe Jake wasn't that impressed but he raids and I'm
like ah I just in the extravagana earlier with Jake and they
were playing a clip from this guy. >> They tried to gang
up to LCA Rob for views and clout and it backfired very epically.
Well I mean it sort of backfired on them as in they failed before
Andrew Wilson came in and just like obliterated people, right?
Like I think Rob just mocked the people and they like lost totally.
Anybody tried to engage him for real got totally owned and basically
the only thing they did was waste a bit of his time and get him
a bunch of donations. Ultimately, he ends with like $800, $900
in donations. That's not Rob owned, right? Rob just worked for
$100 an hour for like 9
That's Rob just won completely. So, I think to me it's like,
okay, Rob won and it didn't have to be bigger. There's like some
extra things that happen here. I don't know. >> Guy that
does these sham. We'll see how it plays out long term. I'm sure
short term there's no downsides for Andrew or Rob in doing this.
I feel like longterm it could lead to lead to some weird things.
I'm sure if also if Andrew really liked the Sarah person, he
probably would have, you know, given her more consideration.
Probably wasn't liking how she was doing stuff for a while. I'm
guessing Rob might have messaged her or somebody might have messaged,
you know, Andrew or somebody at the Crucible about how they didn't
like the moderation on the panels. >> Wild commercials,
right? And that guy might be coming on the extravaganza next
week. So they're messaging me in the back. This toasted guy's
messaged me. He's like, "They'll bring you back up. They'll do
2 minutes. You talk 2 minutes." Then them. I say, "Okay." So
they bring me back up and I just basically say, "Hey, Trippy,
I'll make it up to you, man. Sorry about this. Uh, but you know,
clearly Radical Coder has so much to say and what could I even
say?" So I just wanted to mention that Vince the Shamwow guy
might be coming on the extravaganza next week. So I wanted to
read the famous Shamwow commercial. And that's what I did for
a minute and a half. And then they realized like, oh, this guy's
with us. That's true. I am. And that's what happened. So that's
that's the whole story of what I did yesterday and why I did
it. Tired of people speaking over me. I don't need these people.
The only reason I'm there is for my enjoyment and hopefully the
enjoyment of my audience. It's not enjoyable to me or them if
people were just spuring out talking over me. Moderators weren't
stepping in. I wasn't dealing with it with another night. I said,
"I'm going to sit here quietly until you stop interrupting."
They said, "Great. Then sit there quietly. I said, "You got her,
dude." So now I want to get to Sarah. Sarah then, you saw it,
right? It's not necessarily that Sarah said a bunch of [__]
It's that she sat there while they were talking. That's the issue.
That's the issue. And all these [__] came over from
Dusty's channel last night. First, I dealt with the [__]
from Sarah's panel. It wasn't Sarah's fault, though. It was a
She was doing a panel herself, moderating it with Connor, Connor
points, who I [__] with all the time cuz he's trash.
and one of his supporters came over and he spurked out and got
wrecked. He left. Then this dude came. He was a nice guy, but
man, [__] out there. I talked to him for like an
hour. Now, this is after I closed the showdown. I literally I
was like, "Thank you so much everyone. We do a little thing called
the Griffithon. The show ended. I was just saying my goodbyes.
These people start coming in." Now, these two weren't connected
with Dusty, but the rest of them all were. So, it took me like
half >> Oh, wait. The counterpoints guy was not one of
the trolls, apparently. way through the first caller to realize
I see what's happening. You're a fan of Dusties. And by the time
I got to like caller two or three, I realized, oh, they're probably
all together on a channel. I wasn't surprised when someone after
the stream at like, I don't know, 4:00 a.m. or something, right?
Was like, uh, hey, Dusty's got all these people on the panel
right now. Like I check my phone as I'm hopping in the shower
and surprise surprise, there's Sarah. And I'm like, what the
There she is. Now I'm a off that it's like you you sent me this
unsolicited advice previously and all this.
>> Man, I am seeing a little bit how this came together
like in real time. Now that you're getting all of the all of
like the like the timeline here where Rob he has like this bad
experience with Sarah a couple weeks before he's really pissed
about her message and then he goes on some panel where she's
not involved and then
a little bit later that night he's getting trolled and he goes
and sees a stream where they're all laughing about him laughing
about trolling him right and she's there the person who's giving
him this advice that he thought was really condescending and
that he's not a fan of her panels and her moderation style and
now she's out here openly like [__] him. I can see
how that would be like, "Oh, uh, these people, like, [__]
these people
>> And I kept my mouth shut basically. Yeah, I said your
moderation wasn't that great, but that's it. Ask my channel.
I was like, "Hey, I wish Sarah the best."
>> What's that? >> Do you think Sarah sees it?
>> Does she get it? Does she get that she is um >> Well,
she I think she felt like cuz me personally I felt like oh she
didn't say that much when I just watched a little bit but I was
flunking around VODs right and I didn't catch some of the stuff.
I definitely didn't catch some of the later stuff. Andrew watched
the whole thing. I watched a little bit of the Andrew react well
we watched it on stream today and Andrew listened to her basically
talk about how Rob's
>> too sensitive and I'm like oh no I see. But I don't
I don't think she gets it. I think she thinks like I barely spoke.
Why why would you even be mad at me?
I think that's her opinion.
>> Not really based on anything. I think it's like I barely
spoke. Why would this be? But >> ignorance also isn't like
a defense or anything. But yeah, >> now hold on. Now she
might have changed now with all the reactions. Once she saw once
she saw Andrew and a bunch of other people react, maybe she now
understands
>> I wonder. >> See that?
>> Open panels aren't for me anymore. Good luck to her.
And I I always talked up. I said, "I want people that are right-wing."
This is something that Andrew and me have in common. We want
the right to win everything. Everything. If we have a streamer
with two followers, we want them to crush the left-wing streamer
with two followers.
That's how we feel. So, when it comes, you're going to have people
that do panels and we don't want the left wingers to have the
best panels. We want the right-wingers. It's not something I'm
interested in doing having a panel. Good for Sarah. To this day,
I think Sarah does a good job at setting people up. Like, it's
a pain in the ass to contact multiple people, to get a topic
lined up, to get the people on board, blah blah blah. That's
a pain in the ass. I think Sarah does a fine job with that from
what I've seen. I think she's a terrible [__] moderator.
So, she's giving me this advice. I'm like, "What the [__]
are you doing?" And I hate there's nothing I hate more than like
this fake like, "Let me help you out." Like from a place of condescension.
[__] you. Who the [__] are you?
>> what are you talking >> Hold on. I feel like um
I just want to check this. I don't know if they're they reviewed
some of this stuff. Pisco is live tonight. He had counterpoint.
>> Apparently they went through >> I have to be treated
like a [__]
>> and yeah, apparently they went through or Pisco went
through reviewed some of the Rob stuff. I might be interested
in seeing Pisco's opinion on it. Apparently Counterpoints came
on as well.
Uh I can't imagine this is good, but maybe the Pisco Rob review
could be interesting. Cisco posted that tweet where like he agrees
panelist
what what did he say? >> Well, he posted the clip of Rob
and then at some point later he goes >> I agree though
some moderators be
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. >> talking about. Oh, thanks so much
for your help. Thank you.
Wow. I didn't think of that for your help.
Whation? You like this fake like let me >> Did he actually
say it like that? >> You out like from a place of condenses.
>> he did say condensation. >> Who the are you?
>> What are you talking about? >> Pisco's ultimate
ultimate act of rebellion against ICE is that he will look very
soon like the average illegal immigrant. Okay.
>> Oh my goodness. >> He will not he will not shave.
He will keep getting tans. He's keep He's going to a tanning
bed right now. He is going to be the guy, okay? He's the lawyer
who will get grabbed by ICE, but he's an American citizen. All
right. Pisco is getting ready for his ark. He's getting the tattoos.
He's going to try to get himself deported to CCOT. Okay. So,
he can be the ultimate case against the Trump administration.
>> And the tomato raging tomato. >> Whoops. Whoops.
Whoops. Whoops. I do I do want to see a little bit of Pisco's
opinion on this. We'll see if we can check it out after Rob's
video. We got 20 minutes left on Rob's video. >> Thanks
so much for your help. Thank you.
Wow. I didn't think of that. Here, I thought the panels. >> Yeah,
I should be clear. Don't think he looks bad. I'm just I'm laughing
that it's like uh the mustache, the beard, it's all it's all
working. The messy
>> Even if they were >> I can't really do the goofy
Hispanic accent, but if I could the if I could do the Hispanic
janitor accent, I'd do it. >> Supposed to be a little more
loose. You were still supposed to be able to hear each other.
That's what I thought. Not just talk through it. All right, though.
But whatever. I didn't say anything. Now, if I would have to
while I was showering, turned on Dusty's panel and it would have
just been Dusty and these goofs, I'd have probably started my
show today before the calling show and been like, "Oh, man. Big
Dusty, these trolls." Yeah, >> but why? You got to get
him the You got to get the glasses on him, though. You need the
glasses, Mr. Potato Head. Okay, >> we need the glasses
or it doesn't make any sense. >> I am I am so sorry for
this, Pisco, if you ever see this. >> This is a good look,
by the way. Is a It is a good look. I'm not I'm not I swear to
God I'm not
but if I see a funny meme I click funny meme. Okay, >> I'm
done dealing with these people. Anyways, moving on. >> But
there I saw Sarah. I'm just going to say this. I happen to be
privy to the fact that Sarah and me may be working together in
the future on things like Debatecon or other projects. So I'm
like, why the would you like why would >> So I don't know
if that's been made clear yet. Oh no, Andrew made it clear, right?
Andrew is holding he's running his own debate conference thing.
I I'm >> like it's a debate con used to be modern day debate,
right? >> Am I crazy? That was modern day debate called
their >> Did they call it debatecon? >> I think they
call it debatecon. >> Oh, okay. >> So, I think Andrew
is basically like taken a lot of that over after he went through
and wrecked Matt Dillah Hunty or whatever. Kind of just them
and Matt Dillah Hunty left. So, I think Andrew is like running
it now. and he had set up Sarah to do a bunch of stuff for it
and then Andrew just said, "Oh, Sarah, what am I going to do
with Sarah in Debbon?" "Oh, well, she's gone. This other person
will take it over. I'll pay her whatever I was going to pay her.
[__] that person." Right? So, Rob is also aware of
this behind the scenes that they're going to have a direct professional
relationship. They're going to be working together and he feels
like she's being kind of an passive aggressive and stuff. So,
I think there's another tension added there that isn't transparent
and isn't just a part of the content creator part like piece
of this. >> A little different. >> Would you do this?
Why would you [__] You got something to say? Come
say to my [__] face. You're going to go on a panel
for 3 hours. She sat in that [__] panel cuz I went
back and checked 3 hours. You sat in that [__] panel
while they talk [__] on me and you're yucking it
up and all that [__] Then they intentionally sent
trolls over and you sat there the whole time. Three [__]
hours. I saw this about 30 40 seconds after I [__]
turned Dusty's video on and I about died of laughter. In fact,
I woke my wife up laughing from the bathroom. >> Well,
I think this is what happened. >> Rob just cackling while
taking a [__] >> Happens uh when people [__]
with the panel verse that way, >> right? If you're not
a panel verse person and you come in and you try to [__]
with the panel verse people, like they will all band together.
Like, you just can't do that. You just can't you can't go around
to panel verse shows
and flip out on >> I want to be clear here. She's not just
talking about last night. As I said, she sent me a message on
the eth saying they target you because blah blah blah. And what
I didn't mention was Dusty came on my show on a call-in and got
schooled like the goof he is. So what Sarah's talking about is
why I've been with her friends on her panel what she calls the
panel verse and they're all going to stick together. So, hey,
you got >> Rob just wrecked the panel verse solo. No, he
did not. Okay, he did not. >> Rob is like the Philippines
in World War II or something and the US, which is Andrew Wilson
in this case, just came through and nuked Japan. >> No,
that's that's not fair. You do have to say that he destroyed
it solo because if not for Rob, Andrew doesn't care. He wouldn't
have even looked over here. He had not been paying attention.
He had never put Sarah in check. Obviously, she's grown to appreciate
her viewership and the people who join her panel. So much so
that she did this to Rob.
Rob alone is the one who did this. Just he has friends, he has
allies, and because of him, he Yeah, you have to give it to him.
>> Um I don't I don't know if this would have quite gone
the same way if it weren't for the Andrew connection.
I think you could make the same argument on Andrew's side like
that. Like if Andrew hadn't come through, it would have been
a way different argument, a way different like outcome possibly.
>> I think I think it's like both. Yeah, probably both.
>> But um
yeah, I I also I think Rob could have easily like,
man, I I can't shake the idea that Andrew did this as much to
teach Rob a lesson as it was to teach Sarah a lesson. That it
was like, "Hey, you have to protect your your reputation. Don't
go on these glo shows. Don't let these people come on and just
troll you. Tell these people to off like like they are not worth
your time. You are special. Stop acting like you're one of them.
Stop acting like they deserve your time. Stop acting like your
your place is with like five viewer people with a v with a picture
that's meant to just trash talk you for being fat. You actually
have special talent. Do not waste your time with this loser.
Right? Do not. They are literally flies. They are summer ants.
Okay. Andrew Wilson has to describe it to him like he's low tier
god but white >> because this is a lesson that we see in
other areas, right? This is like the the H3H3 subreddit. You're
you get captured by an like this small number of people
>> who for some reason, you know, Ethan is beholden to
them. He's uh lovebombed by them.
And nobody engaging with Ethan should fall susceptible to like
how they've brained him, right? Did that all connect for you?
cuz I >> Yeah. No, it's it it is the same to me. Um it's
it's also the same if you have
>> it's the same with Ethan.
Oh, there's another example of this. It's this Yeah, you have
this small like motivated infinite time, right? This is what
you were talking about before. They have infinite time. They
will do this forever and it's not worth it. It's like even if
you beat them, even if you win, there's a million more that will
come out of the woodwork with no viewers, no no tangible contribution
back to you and they will take all of your time away and you
will just wither away. And Sarah is a vessel for them to have
like this
>> Because they are small. They won't have very much viewership
without her. And for her, she likes she gets a lot of uh affirmation
from them. She gets a lot of protection. She's like, "Oh, you
put the panel face. They're going to come together and they're
going to protect their own."
Yeah. Sarah's going to realize, okay,
a lot of these people, you expect these people to like be your
friends and stuff. a lot of them.
Um, this doesn't apply to anyone around me. I'm just saying
I sometimes when people have like an interest in being around
you, when there's something else like the Andrew Wilson viewership
that comes in, you'll realize really quickly that it feels like
they're her friends. It feels like you're standing up for them
and then they'll just be gone, right? Like I think I think I
hope she doesn't think that all these people are like truly on
her side. They're all like totally with her for loyalty is gone
as soon as you're no longer useful. You have a platform they
can't exploit. >> Yeah. Yeah. It'll be gone real quick.
>> Got to know you start going after them, they're all
going to brigade your channel. But listen what she says next.
>> Go around to panel verse shows
and
>> flip out on hosts.
>> and get mad at hosts or
Why can't this [__] say plural
>> He's saying it plural >> like a
Yeah, like like a plural arrangement.
>> We've got some plural plural. >> Got some carnations
in our plural >> Listen, you're Canadian.
>> This is a you problem. >> Okay. All right.
>> I chat's totally on my side. I'll just >> with
host shows and do that. >> Get get back in the house, Coral.
>> Kind of stuff and then expect everyone to turn and look
at you and be like, "Oh, yeah. Come on back." >> In other
words, she's saying her that I with her and her show. Why? Cuz
I said her moderation wasn't very good, but that I respected
her and wanted things to go well. Because at one point I was
frustrated when I'm getting [__] spurked over and
someone says, "Nope, I refuse to answer what you talk about."
I said, "Well, it's me or them. There's no sense of me being
here. That's it." Oh, well, you [__] with the panel
verse, >> You know, like I think I think
I think he doesn't know the power of the panel >> I suppose
you're right. I suppose I >> I'll be real that quote gets
worse as you hear it more, right? Like as you start to realize
the panel versus a bunch of like glidos who are actually like
the best of them are probably like the average person realistically
like a lot of people who will go on a show when they have like
no viewers
and the show has low view. It's like not great. Okay. Like you
look at the lineup and it's like
they look kind of demented. I don't I didn't know the >> I
I'm talking I feel like I power the
I have an editor >> whose name is Black Elk who's the best.
>> Uhoh. Uhoh. >> I think I think
>> I think he doesn't know the power of the panel verse.
>> Oh, not the panel verse. Oh no, >> not the panel
verse. Beware the panel. He doesn't want a foul of the panel.
>> I love that they threw counter points in here. I feel
like Counterpoints is a big enough streamer. As much as Counterpoints
is a loser, he's a big enough streamer that he's probably not
on the tier of these guys. You know, >> who can know the
great Sarah Tomato? The power she wields. The power of the pedal
verse. Very good. It's over. >> Dude, that's like also
like Gohan at his weakest, isn't it? I don't even think that's
Mystic saying I I don't even think that's like Mystic powerup
Gohan, is it? No, it's not. This is like Gohan at his weakest.
his like actual weakest.
>> I'm just going to pretend like I know what you're saying.
>> Well, at at least after he goes Super Saiyan, this is
him at his weakest. So, like they picked the wrong This is what
I'm telling you. They don't even know. >> Oh, no. What
the Panverse? Beware the >> The power of the panoverse.
Very good. >> They just they they didn't pick the right
scene. >> It's over 9,000.
Oh, man. Don't with that. >> I told you. I told you guys
he wouldn't get it at all. It's just fake, man. verse. You with
one, they're all coming at you, baby. Oh, come >> I don't
know. This is from the 80s. No, it's too young for Rob. I'm pretty
sure.
>> Now, here's the thing. I appreciate Andrew having my
back. And I appreciate the people in my audience. So, we're like,
"Fuck this. I'm a petty as I'll fully admit it. I'm a petty.
I could be professional.
I could say you and be petty and still work with you." And I
assume that would be the case. If I said just about Sarah today,
I'd still see her at Debatecon and I'd be like, "Hey, what's
up, Sarah?"
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What did you say, Major Dr. Gassley? It's a more known scene.
It will hit with more people. It was the right choice. That scene,
that scene's not known by anybody. Who was he fighting there?
If you think you know that scene,
that scene ain't
You must have You must have been responding to somebody. >> Uh,
more people would know Pokemon. I wouldn't be her friend. I wouldn't
go out to dinner with her. But if I they need help, set up some
chairs, get this set up, we need someone to fill in for a debate,
no problem. I'd do it. I'd be professional. When she gave me
that passive aggressive
>> about the advice, that was October 8th. So after I saw
this, I decided to say, "Hey, by the way, I didn't respond last
>> Yes, they should have just done cell. Which I feel like
Major Dr. Gastley had to respond to somebody else saying they
should just do cell, but I didn't see it. because I thought better
of it was like it's not worth starting drama. But now I responded
and I basically said listen thank you for your unsolicited advice.
You're right. I didn't know the awesome power of the panel verse
but I'll definitely be talking about it tomorrow morning on my
stream if you'd like to join. She's like it's tribal whatever
but I'm busy tomorrow no. And I was like okay just wanted to
give you the opportunity to let you know I'm inviting you on
before I talk about it. And she's like >> I'm sensing some
sarcasm. Very astute. >> Oh, she should have taken the
>> Very quick that one. I was like, not really sarcasm.
She told me to have fun or just uh they'd keep piling. I'll give
you the exact language. Tribal Elizabeth, it's fine. It's a lot
of people aren't happy with you disrespecting Trippy on top of
other things. They all stick up for each other with stuff like
that. I have plans tomorrow. I recommend laughing it off or they'll
just keep poking. So, I told her I would laugh it. I was going
to laugh. >> Ah. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Yeah, she should have she should have gone and talked to Rob.
And also >> it's in your best interest to drop this, >> but
also I do get the impression a little bit and I don't I don't
want to dogpile this person too badly because they're already
dealing with a lot. But I do get the impression that she's like
it's all about Trippy and I don't think she gives a I think she's
probably more pissed about Rob saying you're moderator >> opportunistic
for herself. >> Yeah. It's one of those things cuz I >> I
see that all the time in this space. >> Yeah. Well, I mean
I do that right. I'll try to I'll like do that sometimes. Like
I have like something I want to say and I'll I'll try to like
use a different example so I'm not making it about myself and
sometimes it's just not honest. Okay. It's not honestly how you
feel. You're like actually feel the thing for yourself way more
but you're like oh you over this person. A lot of people do that.
>> She said she sent sarcasm. I said nope. It's not every
day we get to survive the panel verse. But since she was so generous
in offering me some unsolicited advice, I'd like to return the
favor. So I was >> Oh [__] >> She would
tune in to my show today cuz I had a lot of advice to give her.
Then of course the first half of the show, I didn't know what
I was going to do. Part of me was like, don't [__]
insult her. But I started off the show and I knew this was good.
I just pretended to cry and [__] 45 minutes of, oh
my god, I have a [__] wife and kids. A wife and [__]
kids. And now I have the whole damn awful force of the panel
verse after me. You know that [__] And then I went
to the bathroom and I was like, uh, you know what?
This. So I came back and got more serious and was like, I think
you're a dog moderator. Passive
playing favorites
with people that are beneath me. So you I said it then, I'll
say it now. I think there are things that are more important
in life than what I do here. Being a good parent, just being
a good person. And I have nothing that I've seen from Sarah that
suggests that she's not a good parent and she might be a very
nice person in real life. I don't know or care, but I this is
at the end of the day petty online debate drama. That's what
it is. This isn't like someone attacked my family or anything
like that. Okay. Well, uh this is petty online drama.
Uh her is nuked entirely. She lost more money than
Bro, this is crazy for Rob to say this after.
I guess you could make the argument on the other side. Why did
she do this? Why did she risk this when it's petty online drama?
But like again,
I've gone and looked at her playboard before. I It is like tens
of thousands of dollars a month she's very possibly going to
totally lose out on now over petty online drama.
>> Oh yeah.
Um maybe not more than like 15 grand a month or something. Hold
on. I I'll look again. Uh
let me
this one right here is what we're looking for. So this is past
past month is 11,000.
Can you go month over month? Is this something I can look at?
Oh, it looks like in September, although I don't know if this
actually does all of September. It looks like she didn't make
that much. Oh, no. This is only It can only go the last 30 days.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It can only go the last 30 days. Never mind.
Never mind.
Okay, that's why
15K in the last 30 days is pretty crazy, right? Or sorry, 11K,
12K in the last 30 days, that's pretty nuts.
11K last 30 days. Yeah,
>> that's true. >> I think it's pretty wild. >> Every
the other people involved in this, Dusty and the company, they
came on, they trolled me on the channel. Okay, whatever. They
didn't try to get my channel banned to my knowledge. >> Oh,
by the way, that is all 11K. That's just donations. That's no
ads. That's nothing else. That's just 11K in super chats,
which I guess technically YouTube takes 40% of too, bro. Why
don't How come How come people can't get off of super chats?
It's so crazy. Like, so much money comes in through super chats
and so much of it just goes to YouTube. >> Just with me
ruining the show for the night by being trolls making fun of
me. No big deal. So, I'm not asking for her life to be ruined
and I fully intended that I'd probably still end up working with
her. if it was in the context of working with Debatecon or The
Crucible or something like that. And maybe there's some things
behind the scenes that I can't tell you about, but nonetheless,
that's where we were. But then I teed off and was like, "You,
you suck. You're one of the most replaceable people I've ever
seen because you're one of a million that rely on other people
for your show's entertainment."
>> I don't think I got any email back today, Cam. So, we'll
see. Um I don't know. I I didn't get an email back from the guy.
I should send him another email tonight. We'll see if I get one
>> You don't do anything. You're basically a talent show
host. And next up, this person. You ain't moderating. So, and
that's fine. >> In fact, uh, in fact, Cam, you should probably
treat it as if it's just like a no for the foreseeable future,
cuz realistically, I'm going to get annoyed getting asked about
it every day. >> I shouldn't have mentioned it.
>> And, by the way, you just got to be nice to the talent.
That's all. Now, I know I'm a small fry. I'm a small fry. I mean,
I'm bigger than Dusty, but she likes Dusty. Dusty's part of the
click. Connor, I guess, is bigger than me cuz he's buddies with
Destiny, so he gets to big time me. I fully understand that the
bigger person sometimes gets priority over the moderator and
that's fine, but I don't give a that's what I say that I don't
need your ass. See you up. I don't care. So, that's it. That's
where I left it. I made fun of her. We stayed till 3:30. Got
a lot of money. Broke my donut girl. Not as good as night shift
here, but we broke the goal. had some fun, ended the stream,
went to my son's Halloween thing. Now, I happened to notice
that the fantastic Rachel Wilson was watching my show this morning.
She's like, "Wait, what?" I put the link. I was like, "Yeah,
this stupid idiot. That's what she's doing. Talking [__]
me." Oh.
Oh, yeah. Okay. I'm starting to see it all come together. Rachel
went and watched and was not happy about this and probably was
the one who delivered the the like the timeline of events to
Andrew and I could see priming Andrew. Andrew did still go through
it, but I could see Andrew having been primed on exactly like
how this was going and how up it was.
>> Yeah. Never let Andrew see that clip by the way implying
that his wife has any control over him. Uh he'll lose it. >> People
troll me. [__] you. Panel verse, by the way. That's
the best part. That's so [__] cringe. The panel verse.
How [__] smug do you have to be? Well, us in the
panel verse. People just don't understand our power.
No.
I do think, okay, again, I'll explain this a little taken out
of context. I I think like you mess with the panel. She's basically
describing that these are like the most antisocial,
just totally unsocialized, univilized
dregs of YouTube content creation that if you tell them, hey,
you should you shouldn't do this. It's probably a normal thing
to not like spur and interrupt people, they will do that automatically.
I think there's some amount of that she's like describing how
she has like
nothing but the drags there. And >> can you No. Okay.
Do me a favor. explain how if she feels that way, why doesn't
she treat Rob no like he's one of the spurs that are just going
to do that >> Well, she she doesn't cuz Rob's not one of
those guys.
>> But she's say she's saying she's in this panel you panel
verse or whatever and the people who come here are like this.
>> Wouldn't you expect the new people who come to also
be like that? Um, I Well, I think probably not Andrew Wilson
and Rob, the people who are directly involved with the Crucible.
Probably expects them to have some self-control. She probably
is like trying to help them navigate maybe. Although, I mean,
as I hear more of this, it does sound like she maybe got her
ego hurt by Rob, too, and was kind of doing passive aggressive
digs back.
>> It just it sounded like her telling Rob how to act and
feeling like, well, these people are spurs, so I don't tell them.
Well, I think that's I think that is what happened. >> They
don't learn, but I can train you. >> Well, I think that
is what happened. >> Super offensive. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. But I think that is actually what happened. >> What
a cringe thing to say. What are you talking about now? Maybe
she was drinking. I don't know. But holy sh Are you kidding me?
I mean, my goodness.
>> Laughable. And they're all like the whole nature of
it. And you saw it if you're coming from Andrew's show or if
you watched me this morning. They're like all sitting around
after like they got done trolling me and they're all like the
one dude's like, "I don't think we did very good." And they didn't.
And Dusty's like, "No, no, we were all hilarious. We all did
good. We'll try better next time." Or whatever. That's the panoverseverse,
baby. They can't even [__] >> That's funny.
>> They have to have little pep talks of themselves after
they fail at trolling. How hard is it to troll?
They couldn't even do that. They did. I swear they did. Here,
wait. This guy in the top right is one of the guys that called
in to troll. The guy below trolled. I think >> Well, I
want to be the bigger person here. say that we got smoked, y'all.
We got to, you know, take our losses on the chest. It's true.
Even I I don't know anything about the guy. I'll be I'll be fair
here. I just know that he's like a standard conservative. But,
uh, ortho, >> we got smoked, y'all. We got smoked. >> Pretty
bad showing. The other guy, what's the guy with the hat? >> Really
bad. I mean, that was following that was just like I was so secondhand
embarrassed. I wanted to cry. But we can do better next time.
What? We're going to win. And >> this is their trolls admitting
how they are. I mean, you >> This guy did kind of get rolled
by Rob and then >> you can't even troll
>> the song Olympics
# >> I wasn't I wasn't there to I wasn't there to troll
him. Like I >> they're coping about their failures to >> I'm
annoyed.
>> Like I'm genuinely annoyed with him. >> Dusty,
come on. Get in here, man. Pep him up. Give him the pep talk,
baby. >> Everybody did great. Um it was actually funny
as >> we all did great. Ignore that. We did great. You
guys are super. You're the best. We did great. And then Sarah.
Yeah. Let's play it one more time. It's Let's hear it. Sarah,
>> tell us about the >> awesome power of the panel
verse. Are you ready? >> Well, I think this is what happens
uh when people with the panel verse that >> right? If you're
not a panel verse person and you come in and you try to with
the panel verse people, like they will all band together. Like
you just can't do that. You just can't you can't go around to
panel verse shows. >> Oh, I see what you're saying. John
smoking.
Uh if these guys are representative of the panel verse that Yes.
Which is just sad. >> And flip out on hosts and get mad
at hosts or with host shows and do that kind of stuff and then
expect everyone to turn and look at you and be like, "Oh yeah,
come on back. >> I don't want to come back. You want me?"
>> You know, like >> here we go. This is the This
is greatest maybe the greatest [__] line that I've
heard in the past month streaming. >> I think he doesn't
know the power of the panel verse. >> I guess you're right,
Sarah. I guess he can't just with the panel verse, huh? So that's
it. That's the I talk the power of the panel verse line is the
least offensive part there where he's describing she's describing
things that she's bothered by and using the other people as like
a pretext for discussing it. And it is kind of talking and it
is kind of there's there's ego there as well. And
that's That's tough. That's a tough lesson to learn. You get
your your biggest supporter, the biggest like adjacent creator
you have just like pulls support entirely because you as friend.
That's um I don't know. I hope I hope she does well. I hope she
can come back from that. We'll see. Um money might be a little
tight or whatever for super chats, but I'm sure like a lot of
the stream still works, right? I'm sure her open panel nights
are pretty funny. I talked me some and that's it. I'm ready to
move on. The answer is no. Hey Rob, Sarah's having an open panel.
Will you go? No. Hey Rob, radical coder wants to know fuel. No.
Hey Dusty would like you to No, that's it. Done with all these
people. I don't care. Uh if they they could go on to become the
next Joe Rogan with billion dollars and I'll say good for them.
Don't care. I'll tell you exactly what happened. I don't think
Andrew would mind this at all. I'm at this event, this Halloween
event with my son and I get a phone call from Andrew. He calls
and I go outside and I talk to him and he's like, "What's >> Oh
[__] I didn't hear any of this part. what going on
with Sarah? What's going on? And I was like, don't even don't
worry about it, man. Just don't worry about it. And he's like,
well, just tell me. And I was like, well, listen, she big times
me. She lets these people talk over me in her panels and I'm
done with it. And she's sending me DMs basically like, you know,
oh, let me give you some advice and blah blah blah. He's like,
>> Sarah's the raging tomato. We looked at her channel
just a second ago. It's this channel. Um,
Sarah the Raging Tomato. She had 20,000 subs or something. She
lost 3,300 already. That's rough. Her channel's getting giga
brigaded now.
I like, yeah, it's ridiculous. And I was like, so last night
I'm tired of dealing with these people. I go on this panel or
this debate and they're talking over me again. So I thought it'd
be funny to give a little How you like this apples? Oh, you're
right. You want me to be silent so you could talk? You're happy
with that? Fine. Go. I like them apples,
>> You got two hours. Enjoy. Brief side note. I did [__]
Trippy over. I don't know. Trippy. I don't know if Trippy's a
member of the panel verse or not. He's in a tight spot. That
Nova chick that was uh moderating. I don't think she knew what
the [__] she was doing. And I don't mean that in
a bad way. I just think she didn't know what her role was. It's
like I think I'm just supposed to be here and switch the cameras.
And Trippy though didn't do anything to me. Trippy said afterwards
that I disrespected him. I did and he's right to be and he didn't
deserve that. I did what I thought was right by me because these
two idiots, these interrupterss, but it was at the expense of
Trippy's panel and I actually feel bad for that and I will reach
out to Trippy and I don't think anyone should be mad at Trippy.
Now, if he decides to be like, "Fuck you, I hate you, blah blah
blah." I'll say, "Okay, well, I tried. Goodbye." I him over.
I did. And I am sorry for that. I I legitimately mean that. And
the guy toasted that set up the debate, I [__] him
over. But that's it. So, if I will try to make it up to Trippy,
I'll be like, "Hey, man. If you want to do a different debate,
me verse you, you have an opponent you would like me to pick
as long as it's reasonable. You want to just have me on. I'll
raid over to you with all of my subs. I'll tell everyone like,
"Please give this guy chance." I think he's always been reasonable
when I've heard it. I really mean all of that. So, I tell I tell
him, I'm like, "Yeah." I was like, "Well, you [__]
basically don't have anything without me. So, [__]
it. You're telling me to be quiet because you want to talk more
and that's a good thing? Then I'll be quiet for 2 hours. Enjoy."
Then as I you know that I told Andrew that and I was like then
I did a little joke with the shamwow when they brought me back
on with them. Okay. And I was like so the night ends and I check
you know someone sends me a message like
they're they're all pow-wowing
talking about trolling you and I go on and I was like there's
Sarah tomato again. It wasn't enough. She's super passive aggressive
DMing me a couple weeks ago. By the way I didn't say to anyone
about it. So I'm like I don't now I know. And the reason that
Andrew is calling me is because Andrew
works with Sarah. She books debates for him. And so I'm like,
Andrew took a chance on me. So the last thing I want to do is
cause problems
within his operation and he's got a ton of [__] going
on which I happen to be privy of. So I don't want to cause him
any. I said, "Don't worry about it. Don't worry." And he said
basically what you heard tonight. Wouldn't matter if you're right
or wrong. We're friends. I got your back,
but you're not wrong. She said, "The last thing I told her was
nepotism. We got each other's backs. We don't each other in the
back. You don't go on a panel that you weren't on with a bunch
of people trolling one of us and sit there and yuck it up and
talk about how, oh, you messed with the power. You don't do it.
So, and if she'll do this to you, she'll do it to me." I would
have no problem if Andrew was like, Sarah, that was a scummy
thing. Anyways, let's move forward. I would say fair enough.
I didn't run to Andrew. Andrew didn't feel the need that like
>> I hope Rob understands that like if he feels if he feels
bad at all about this happening like
>> feels bad about what >> if he feels bad about
Sarah's channel getting like kind of I assume it'll be fairly
decimated by this. Maybe not. Maybe it'll be totally fine. But
I I assume that if he if he ever feels bad about this, he's got
to understand, all right, you got to protect your optics. All
right. You can't can't take all these trolls in. get a whole
bunch of troll calls and just like entertain them the whole time.
Uh I don't know. Maybe it is fine. Maybe that's who he is. >> What
do you What >> I feel like there's like some lesson here
for Rob about like Andrew to come in and protect Rob's optics
cuz Rob's not doing the like all the things he needs to like
managing his time well. >> No, but I'm saying I don't think
it's just Rob's op I don't think it's just Rob's optics that
Andrew is protecting. It's also in Andrew's interest. >> Yeah,
it is right. >> 100%. Yep. It's like both in Andrew. >> These
are red flags in a This is red flags in a panel host, a panel
moderator >> that I'm going to employ or have been >> that
I've been employing. Yes.
>> Yeah. 100%.
>> Yep. Yep. >> I got to have Rob's back. That's
not what happened. What happened was she stupidly went in that
panel that was public that people that watch her show and mine
would see. And once you make it public then >> this is
this is the problem evil Morty is I or sorry wired rope is I
think there's a lot of reason people could run with this narrative
and I don't think Rob will like that and I don't think Andrew
wants that narrative to be run against Rob. >> Wait with
what narrative? >> Uh that that Rob had to be saved by
daddy, right? Like people will say that.
>> I don't think that's true. I think he did fine with
all those trolls. I think he kind of just cut them all down.
But I think people will run with that. Luckily for Rob, I just
don't think there's anybody unless Pisco picks it up, but I don't
even think Pisco does drama like this. We'll see what Pisco's
opinions are, but I don't think anybody smart enough to pick
this up or and run that narrative will do it. Like I think basically
anyone anyone who wanted to be like, "Oh, Rob's Rob's getting
saved by Andrew Wilson because he can't fight his own." Anyone
who wanted to do that is is not going to pick this up.
I think he's fine on that one. I think Pisco on the beginning
of the live and learn stuff referenced Rob a little bit
saying how
going back and looking at some of his older panels or debates
with Rob that he's way kinder to Rob than he probably should
have been that Rob like interrupts. They were talking about like
the fatigue of debating Rob nor >> Nor fatigue. >> Yeah,
Josiah had forgotten that Hutch had ever been on panels with
Rob before and stuff like that. there.
>> I think that was all to say how like Pisco never ended
up having that one day a week podcast with Rob Norah. >> There's
no uh there's no
Did they talk more or less about Rob than they did about Josiah
actually retiring from their podcast? >> Maybe equal. >> Oh,
odd. But okay, >> I'm going to respond in public.
That's that. I don't know that other than I assume Andrew's family.
I don't know anyone that has as much admiration for what Andrew's
done in this space than me. Partially
>> uh what about me? I I at least sit here in awe of Andrew
and the [__] he's built. Yeah. >> Like I remember
I point this out all the time that I've got like tons of respect
for Andrew in that the first time I watched him he my my mind
was like so I I want to say it was like my view of him was so
warped because I watched him in like a debate with Destiny. I
think twice before I'd ever seen him in any other independent
scenario. And Destiny's very good at trying to make somebody
look absurd or or bad, right? That's like actually the thing
he's probably best at is making the other person look stupid.
And I thought Andrew Wilson was stupid until I saw him debate
somewhere else. And I think he had to get away from debating
Destiny for a while going in his own direction to build up his
own thing and get things going his direction. Which, by the way,
Andrew's really good at making people look stupid, too. Not really
like winning or convincing people. >> Goes right back to
the argument why I can't host panels. I can't I probably should
right now finding the truth. >> No, I can't shut up. That's
the thing. I can't even pretend like I like Andrew. I have him
and his wife blocked. >> I think the the most that they
engage with me for like the past couple years >> is being
nice to me for a moment and then they remind me that I was like
a [__] and I like deserved everything that I got.
>> Yeah. I don't think they're good people. I This is one
of those things. Do you remember when we discussed like Myron
>> Well, I feel like sometimes they're good people. There
were times where Rachel was really nice to me and then sometimes
she's just like, "Oh yeah, you were like a and you deserved like
the things that happened to you cuz you're one of those leppy
women." And then I'm just like, "Okay, I have to block these
people cuz I'm like sensitive right now." >> Kind of like,
yeah, that's a really weird engagement to have. I just feel like
um that does come out with like Andrew Wilson as well that he'll
say he's a Christian and then he'll act in like a totally
>> and and he he argues he'll act in a totally non-Christian
way and then he'll argue like oh people who don't believe in
Christianity tell me I should act more Christian. It's like no
I just think you could probably be kind to people when you don't
have to. >> I like what I see when he's like defending
Rob right here and stuff like that. But I never know which version
of them that I'm gonna see. So it's just
>> I'm sensitive. I'm just gonna block them. When I when
I talk about >> Yeah. And when I talk about why I uh why
I am kind of in awe of Andrew Wilson, it's mostly that there
was a time where I kind of thought he was like a which is wrong.
But then to see that and then I look at like the most super chatted
channels across the entire internet for like the year of our
Lord 2024 and it's The Crucible like number three in the United
States and it's like oh he went from nothing to oh this guy's
massive. This guy is like the biggest channel for 2024. I think
he's in the top. He's number six. $300,000 in 2024.
So, all of 2024, it's like Tim Pool and then him.
Um, and the enforcer, I don't even know who this is. I don't
know who these first four guys are. Never heard of him.
Um, but then the Crucibles number six. It's like going from the
guy who I thought was just getting like totally destroyed to,
you know, he recovers, he goes, he he figures out the arguments
he's going to make and then he comes up with some business plan
where this is where he ends up. I find that respectable even
if I don't think the person is necessarily nice or whatever.
Yeah. I just I'm like, "Oh." So I I just say when Rob says, "Oh,
I built up a channel or sorry, when Rob says he's the only person
who's in awe of what Andrew did." It's like, "No, I I can see
it and I respect it as like a content creator. I respect like
the drive to build something like that if not the
how kind the person is who built it >> because you >> I've
been in space roughly around the same time as him and I have
seen just how damn impressive it is of what he's built and what
he's been able to accomplish. I have one thing going for me.
Um well I got a couple but I'm a good debater. That's
Andrew is a good debater. Angie's one of the best debaters, but
he's also an amazing planner coordinator.
He he has an eye for building a community like I've never seen.
The I have everything that my channel is right now when it comes
to the growth that I've received since I've gone full-time. Everything
is literally either directly modeled from Andrew's channel. Um,
you could say this poop my pants off, but I'm more talking about
the way he strategized to build his community and stuff as Rob
is right. Like I don't I don't necessarily think it's a lot of
true engagement with points. Like it is a lot of dialogue trees,
but that's all of the debate lord type people. They just do the
same dialogue tree stuff in my opinion. Um, it's why debates
kind of just don't work for me. Like I I like debate content,
u any sort of like open conversation is way better where you're
not trying to have one person win or the other person
>> But for the content that he did, he was very smart about
it. For as much as he went on the whatever podcast, he was a
tool for them, but he wasn't a tool that he hoped he could turn
into something as soon as he went home. Cuz he had his wife Rachel
at home turning the stream on live reacting to it. they had like
an agreement or whatever. She was able to live react to him.
So, it's like his audience did not have to turn into the whatever
podcast audience. He retained >> Well, I think he I think
he actually absorbed a ton of their audience. Like I think he
actually it was a bit of a I don't know if it's an intentional
Trojan horse. It it probably worked in synergy for quite a while.
>> And how the did it work? Because he is on that podcast
talking about how I don't need to hear from you feminists or
you women. And he had a woman at home sitting there reacting.
She's like taking the reigns at home. >> She's like on
camera sometimes and stuff like that. And they all supported
then. Yeah. They were donating to her while she's watching him
so she can talk and comment. It's just it was so funny and >> I
think um I think that's the funny thing is she wrote a book.
I've I think it was Lav was telling me like the the book is like
not bad. >> Wait, what is it? You're talking the feminism
occult or something like that. >> Yeah, I thought I thought
Lav had told me the book wasn't bad or something. >> Been
on Fox News to talk about her book. >> Oh, I didn't even
know that. >> Yeah, she hated feminist um before it was,
you know, a trendy thing to do >> Hey says she's just an
extension of him. Not a very feminist take on your part, Tan.
Very surprising. Very misogynistic take. Okay. Don't appreciate
that
>> or through him telling me to do things that are slightly
different in person telling me what to do. So, um, I owe 90%
of my channel's success to Andrew.
I toiled away for years. Andrew used to tell me, he'd be like,
"Listen, dude. What are you doing? Like, you're getting blacklisted.
These are screwing with you. You're getting mass reported." I
didn't believe it. All of a sudden, bam, 13 videos removed. Two
community strikes within a 10-minute period over nothing. He
said, "You got to be careful. You got to be careful who you're
going on with. These are trying to take you down in this TW."
Cuz I was sort of on the Twitch politics sphere. I'm naive, man.
I'm doing the
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Told you. >> See, Kuryoko,
yeah, you did tell me that trying to mass report his channel.
>> These are the type of people who
some of them hung around those Twitch poll
>> Oh, like some of the debaters, some of the people who'
be on these these shows. Yeah. Yeah. >> You know, while
I was toiling away at a home healthcare job, Andrew took a chance
on himself, which is another >> Well, that's what they
think. Oh, I see. Taken. I see that that it's not that you're
not saying that that she's an extension of him. The people who
donate think she's an extension of him. >> I think is so
impressive >> that he really took a chance on himself and
uh built what he has and he's one of the biggest streamers conservative
and I don't mean biggest monetarily. I don't mean biggest viewers.
I mean, biggest in that even people that you would say arguably
have more of a reach than Andrew are literally taking Andrew's
philosophy and talking points and running with it. Watch Matt
Walsh talk about trans issues or something. That's Andrew. Talk
about feminism. That's Andrew. He is saying stuff in the space
and has been saying it for three years that people now are just
willing to say in the mainstream. Andrew Wilson one day. Well,
I think it's more that Andrew Wilson took the time to like work
those dialogue trees out and test them against people who were
debaters and now the people on the Daily Wire copy them because
they just think that they could they they don't have to do any
of the work. None of the work is required. What's KRD?
Google it. >> Okay. Well, I'm doing home healthcare working
100 hours a week. I'm not joking you, by the way. I did work
100 hour weeks because I had to be at work 24/7 at least. I somebody
said it's Keithan Rousan and Destiny.
>> earlier today when I asked. Okay. >> Half the
week I did home. >> Uh just think about it when it says
Andrew Wilson will KRD for Rob No >> healthcare with adults
with disabilities. Long story short, not to get into it, I I
would stream when my sleep chip would start and I had a really
bad day at work. the gentleman that I take care of primarily
was was having some rough health outcomes and it looked as if
I would probably not be able to continue that line of work any
so I was bummed. I was like so I did a stream and it's like hey
man prayers to my my client that I take care of cuz the health
is looking very poor and I was like I don't know what's going
to happen like with my job and we'll make it work. 5 minutes
after I get off stream Andrew text me hey man you got time for
a call? I said, "Yeah, what's going on?" So, I talked to him.
Here's the thing. There's certain things that you can't talk
about on air that you could talk about behind the scenes. So,
I give him a little more details that I wouldn't be comfortable
talking about on air, just the specifics of my job, etc. He's
like, "Come work for the Crucible." And I was like, "I don't
know, man." Like, he's like, "How much would it cost?"
And I was like, "Man, my number one duty in the world is to provide
for my wife and for my son." And he was like, "Yeah, well, let's
work something out." and we did and I've been working for the
Crucible ever since. But not only that, I was able to stream
full-time. And Andrew used to tell me like, "Dude, you could
make it as a full-time streamer." I'd be like, "Ah, [__]
You're just saying that because you're a friend. You're being
nice." But he's right. And uh that that changed my life. If tomorrow
my channel got demonetized and for whatever reason, Andrew was
like, "Hey, Rob, it's been real, but I've decided my wife and
our family are we're moving to the and living off the grid the
rest of our
Peace. see you, you know, sorry I can't pay you anymore. You'd
never do that. But if that was the case, he's changed my life.
I would never forget forget it. Just having these past six months
to do things like be able to go to te-ball games with my son,
to be home every night, to be able to read to my son every night
when I literally my son was growing up without me. That's what
was happening. That I will never forget that. I will always have
Andrew's back. I don't give a no matter what. Now, here's the
thing, though. I'm not the only one that Andrew's helped out
in significant ways. And Andrew is the exact type of guy. I've
said this for three years. So many people portray themselves
as these nice, friendly people online and then they're pieces
of [__] that can't wait to you in the back.
Andrew is a guy who portrays that people at least pretend is
portrayed as this
terrible character who's the nicest guy in the world behind the
scenes. I've said that for years. I was like, it's like he inverted
it. Everyone else is, "Oh, you're the best. You're great. Can
you do me a favor? Can you do this panel for me? And then they're
you behind the scenes. Not Andrew. Andrew used to give me, "Would
you be interested in going on some bigger shows?" Sure. Then
why aren't you? I don't know anyone. Why didn't you ask me? Cuz
I don't want to bother you. What the [__] your problem?
You want to get on bigger show? Let me know. Let's do it. All
of that was before tonight. And what Andrew did tonight uh was
probably one of the kindest things that anyone has ever said
about me. not only talking me up to his audience, but unquestionably
like, "Yeah, [__] it. I got your back. That's it.
[__] it." Andrew says I'm a better debater than him.
That's not true. There are certain topics that I could debate
better than Andrew. I was hanging out with Andrew a couple weeks
ago and I bet I sat there silently and listened to him talk to
me about the Orthodox faith for probably 3 hours. There is zero
chance that I would have any remote chance in a philosophical
debate or religious debate with Andrew. There's some political
normative politics debate that I'd probably beat Andrew like
for debate. >> Oh, it's like the exact things like tariffs
or something like that maybe. But anything when it comes to the
film >> you don't help me like this. Well, difficult to
say. >> Philosophical. I just >> believe it or not,
I am just a dumb redneck. I don't really think that way. I think
just like
>> I don't understand philosophy that much. I'm more the
kind of person that's like, "Oh, something needs done. I guess
someone's got to do it. That's it. Not like, well, why? Um, but
but I can because I debated in college, but he is he
it was very kind of him to say that. It really is. >> Damn.
Okay, so there's there's this guy. We have Rob actually went
live today and actually started talking more about this stuff.
I think he went live with Trippy. Talked to Trippy for a little
bit, right? Am I crazy? Or is this this Trippy? Oh, never mind.
Hold on. This is
>> No, I think it was Ryan Radical Coder. their side, right?
>> Well, Ryan comes on later, I think. >> so it looks
like Trippy and uh I already forgot the I already lost this guy's
name. God damn it. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Speak easy. Speak easy. Thank god. Holy sh.
>> I'm going to go back to listening. I got to cook. >> Okay.
All right. >> Tonight like cuz I assume there's enough
Are you serious, Rob? You get rid of your YouTube VOD? Are you
serious? I want to watch your YouTube VOD. I want to watch your
your content from tonight and it's all gone. Rob, seriously,
Rob,
what the man? What the [__] Rob?
and it did. And I was fed up for a long time about what >> we
never we never saw >> I saw handling are being handled
by other moderators that aren't you because you've never moderated
a debate, nor were you moderating that debate. Just so we're
clear to everyone. Trippy was hosting the debate, but you weren't
the moderator. You were my debate partner. >> That's the
thing. I was your debate partner, and I had told uh Novaar that
she would be the host, but I didn't set her up to have any kind
of control. So, that's on me, too. I was basically pulling moderator.
And I kind of I definitely should have been more your partner
throughout it, you know, like I should have said things. I was
like, >> well, let me basically sitting there letting you
do all the work. >> Let me defend you and Nova for that.
Nova, the worst I could say about her is this. Now, for all I
know, people sent me clips that were like, Nova was on with Dusty
and them talking [__] on you. That's okay. I don't
mind. I put her in a shitty position. I said the same thing about
Toasted. Toasted came on my Discord and I don't know. I guess
he was pushing me a little. I don't even give a I told him straight
up. I'm like, you can call me a or whatever you want, but but
what was frustrating to me was he was simultaneously saying,
"Oh, I don't think you did anything wrong visa v Sarah." But
then he was on Sarah's Discord at the same time basically saying
I was an [__] and someone showed me the link. And
I'm like, why you got to be duplicitous? You could have just
been on anyways. Neither here nor there. Nova, the worst I could
say about her is she probably didn't know exactly what was going
on or she was an
>> We're down to moral fellows. I want to yolo my house
payment. Don't do that. >> Moderator. Either way, perfectly
reasonable. Not upset with her. >> And that's on me, man.
>> Well, no, she she was so nervous. But
>> dude, this is so rough watching all the people I'm sure
all of the people that would have been on like Sarah's side,
you'll just see all of them migrate over now that Andrew made
his ruling, right? Andrew gives his ruling and I'm pretty sure
that entire like panel vers just like ah,
you know, maybe we're just going to maybe you were kind of rude
to Rob actually >> before the show started. Yes. I >> I
was like, just be there. Just sit there. Look pretty. That's
what I told >> Toasted set this up. And like I'm not trying
to listen. I know that Toasted Me had a bit of a falling out.
It's not that big of a deal. I'm not super >> I don't understand
why Rob streaming
from with Speak Easy Overlay. What? I don't know what's going
on here. >> No, no, no. You said they're the only ones.
So, I was like, we'll see. If you're wrong, you're banned for
the day or so. I didn't say a day, but usually my bands are a
day or two days. I brought them back 2 days later. Wasn't a big
deal. He was wrong. He equivocated by being like, "Or you said
something like that." Something like that doesn't mean, "Oh,
you said that both sides commit violence, but the left is worse."
You understand? That's not something like that. Nonetheless,
then on Sarah's panel, he was spuring out over me, making [__]
up, and you know, blatantly admitting, "Yeah, I'm not going to
stop talking over you." And at one point, Sarah says on that
panel, "He keeps talking over you because you're asking him not
to."
What? Like, okay, nonetheless, it doesn't matter. It's no big
deal. Life goes on. I told my audience, I was frustrated with
the moderation and the open panel. But you go back and watch
my video. What I said after being frustrated when I left it,
sort of frustrated. I was like, you know, but Sarah's great.
I wish her well. I hope her channel thrives. I don't know that
I'll do the open panel anymore because of people like Dusty and
Ryan, right? Because they're always spuring out and talking over
people. Anyways, I get on that panel. Now, I'll defend you and
I'll defend Nova and saying this. It is not the worst I've ever
been interrupted. It was in a P. So, in a vacuum, if that's all
you've seen, you might be like, I don't know. It didn't seem
all of that bad. It was annoying. I stand by it. It was bad.
And I was like, here we go. It's going to be all night. But it
was because of the pattern that I'd seen from this crowd. It's
not serious debates. It's them spuring out. >> And when
I said, and I got to give Ryan credit for this, right, for sort
of calling my bluff when I was like, "Listen, man. Then I'll
sit here quietly until you stop interrupt." And he came back
with a smart ass. Great. That's more time for me to talk. Now
I'm in a weird position in a >> Okay, I need some new information
here. Can we get some new What's going on? Okay, we got Ryan
coming in. This will actually be interesting. All right, >> release
DMs and [__] like that. >> Watch when Radical
comes on.
>> If I can't get into it then I'm like
>> I got the DMs she sent me in private. She would have
never been like from leaving that. >> I don't have the
discipline right now. I need something to spark inspiration.
Okay. I need something to come along and wake me up. Wake me
up. >> And I'd be like, anyways, what's the news of the
day? See you there, bud.
>> Look, man. You >> He's actually in the back, too.
He's been crying to come up and I said, I'll ask Rob when he's
done. >> Bring him up. I'll give him five minutes. Go ahead.
>> dude. Are they Oh, Speak Easy. Totally.
Speak Easyy's there. Speak Easy has this covered. Okay, we cover
the new right-wing racist group chat. Yeah, probably. There's
cool [__]
>> Hey guys. Now, Ryan, you goof. You think that I seriously
was afraid to debate you that you prepped hard this one time?
That's your honest to goodness opinion of what happened there.
>> Well, he did prep. I can I can >> Oh, no. I
believe you prepped. You said I I saw it. Someone sent me the
clip of you on Dusty's channel that your feeling is that I saw
that you did prep and was looking for an out.
>> I think there is something to that, but I I don't think
it's the main reason you >> I mean, come on. Do you really
think I hope you prepped? I love debating people. I love debating
people that are beating me around on topics. With you, it'll
never happen for two reasons. One, because you're not capable.
And second, because you're not going to get the chance. But but
you know, neither here nor there. >> Which section of the
Insurrection Act do you want Trump to invoke? >> Uh what
was uh 252?
The one I read in my opening statement.
>> So 253 probably. That's >> I can't remember those
specific one I read in my opening statement. Doesn't matter.
Your partner already conceded that legally it can be invoked.
So the legality of it's not important.
>> No, the clown is not Sarah the tomato. The clown is
trippy. The trippy cast >> What matters is
the practic you know what I need to to practice is doing more
of um
>> I need to do in my off time because I hate doing it
on stream. >> I'm going to commit. Okay, hold on. I'm do
starting in November. I'm gonna do three 30 minute sessions a
week of practicing with um Excalibur because I need to be able
to I need to be able to graph out ideas better. I need to take
moments from stream like this one and clip them for myself and
then be like how would I draw this exact thing I'm thinking of
with Excal.
I'm I'm pretty used to like diagramming tools from being a software
engineer
and I think it would just be a lot more helpful if I could do
that. If I could just show you like okay
the the how this drama lays out, right? I also think it would
be it would be a cool way to explore things >> which scalcadraw
this excalad draw whiteboard
re-education
this is I don't know what this is for but it's just like little
little diagrams you do boxes okay you do boxes you can connect
them with arrows boxes connect
then if uh then if you move this guy around hold on you move
this guy around his his arrows connected oh you should be connected
to this box
right now. When this box moves, well, you're kind of on an edge
there,
you know,
great for prototyping ideas. I think it'd be good for explaining
and laying out certain things in context as well. I just haven't
ever thought about how to do it precisely. And I think there's
just I think there's like a couple different abstractions you
could lay out. Like if I could walk through timelines, if I could
if I knew how to do timelines with this a lot better or if there
was like a library that did timelines well, I think building
out timelines for dramas would be really cool. Like if you're
doing like some kind of review and you had a solid timeline layout
that you could go and insert things like as you get facts, I
feel like that would be awesome,
right? I think that would be great. But I alas I don't know how
to lay it out. I don't know how to make it easy enough.
Can you draw on this? You can draw on this. Oh, hold on. You
draw on the overlay over whatever you're watching. Oh, I mean,
you could set something like that, but set up something like
that, but like I don't know if you would do that. You can just
freehand draw, too. I don't know. I should get really much better
at this. I think this would be something that would be very effective
for a lot of drama stuff like John Madden kind of. It's just
a good way to conceptualize stuff, conceptualize relationships,
right? Like I think for a lot of dramas, a lot of the more involved
dramas, like let's say the super mega drama, if you had like
a a graph of relationships for the super mega drama, I think
it would make it a lot easier for the the crowd to process. The
super mega drama, there's a lot of people come like in and out
of that. I forget some of the players there cuz I'm I just wasn't
super in it at the time. Cherry, nobody could hear Cherry, okay?
And thank God for that. She just said, "Do you ever get tired
of going over the same speech, calling me out on being a lazy
who's never actually done this and explained this idea like four
times?"
That's [__] up. And then I have to reiterate that
to you guys so I don't feel like an [__] for saying
thank god nobody can hear her.
Life
life.
>> Yes. I think the fact that we see violence against federal
officers means
well I had to explain her point cuz if I just said what I said
then I'd just be an [__] Okay. And yeah she did.
She did kind of get me. >> We if the police there are unwilling
or unccapable of defending the federal
>> Uncapable. Rob uncapable >> is the absolutely
we should send in people from the National Guard to protect them
once you concede the legality. What's it matter what section
I want to invoke?
>> Now the only legality is >> I would sorry I was
I would say that the legal the legality of it is kind of disputable
because it's not something that is uh that can't be reviewed
by the courts right so like even if Trump does it the circumstances
by which like the standard by which he's invoking it still can
be reviewed. >> Well sure they can but it doesn't matter.
Your partner conceded the legality of it. You could have disagreed,
but for the purposes of me in that point where we left off in
the debate, your side had conceded the legality. I still think,
in fact, there was a ruling today, which was the point you were
interrupting me on when I got frustrated, there was a ruling
today that stayed the court's order that said that Trump couldn't
send him. And now we have National Guard troops on their way
to Portland. As I told you, would be the case. It's clear-cut
that they're going to win that legal case that he has the right
to do this, >> but not to like National Guard's not going
there to enforce local laws, right? Well, I believe they're going
there I to protect, right, the federal troops. And part of that
could be the enforcement of local laws if the people are breaking
the laws in ways that don't directly attack federal troops, but
are setting up things that would be dangerous for people that
are supporting ICE or for the transportation and the entrance
exit into ICE facilities.
>> Wait, is the super mega drama bad? First I've heard
of it. Well, the super mega drama was basically them getting
accused of allowing woman to be insulted and then covering it
up. It was it was good. Uh, a lot of the players who were making
the accusations, the people who were making those accusations
ended up like pretty badly lying and misrepresenting things.
And so it got very interesting. >> For example, if they
decide to blockade a street, you would say, well, that's not
National Guard's job to arrest them. But it is if it's they think
that it's going to be an incoming secondderee threat to the people
that are there to enforce the federal law. ICE.
So, and the other thing is I would have asked you, right? You
said, well, when this was last invoked, like Rodney King, am
I right? It's the last time it was invoked, right? >> You
said that it resulted in a bunch of deaths. Correct.
>> How long ago was this? I don't know. Two years ago,
two and a half years ago. >> Before it was invoked. before
it was invoked there were yeah there were there were 50 plus
uh people had been there were un alive sorry um there were uh
there were a thousand thousand people who had been injured a
thousand burn buildings had been burned and the police were literally
incapable of of executing the laws that was a very particular
circumstance clearly isn't going on right now >> so I misunderstood
but if you would have
>> sorry this just got linked by neoc in the discord I
just this hits okay when your AI girlfriend was on AWS US East1
I don't know if you guys saw the AWS US outage earlier today
that [__] everything. That just hits. Okay, that's
a good meme. That's a good meme.
>> Then I would say great. Then after it was invoked, did
the damage continue or was it precipitously declined?
>> Uh I imagine that it was fairly quickly >> So
then what was the exact timeline? >> What was the harm
of sending those troops in? >> I'm not saying there was
harm at the in9
I'm not I'm not arguing whether or not I was justified to invoke
it in '92. >> Okay. So then the question would be, you
don't really have a reason that practically or it would be bad
that it would make the situation worse. You're just making a
legal claim, which to me it seemed like your opponent had already
conceded, which you'll admit he conceded the legal argument.
>> So I'm making I'm making two parts, right? I I think
legally it's dubious to say the least. I I don't think most of
the condition I I think a lot of legal scholars view 253 as being
in context of 252. A lot of people have been critical of how
it's of the vagory of it. In fact, something we would have gotten
into if we were debating longer is that 253 if read just 253
section uh two specifically um would be uh if if read just on
its face would allow uh basically the the president to invoke
the insurrection act to send the military to even if even like
two people conspired to break federal law which I think even
you would acknowledge is kind of ridiculous bar. >> Well,
I mean it depend. Now here's the problem, right? You would imply
that the insurrection act could be used to quell insurrections.
Correct. >> Okay. I am not watching I'm not watching a
debate on this to be honest. I probably just need I need a topic
shift no matter what. I need to cool my head on this. I'm like
I'm zombieing a little bit. All right. instead of actually doing
my